yeah chin we're good to go dude yeah
we're a little fired up it's a little
somber
somber somber day city's on fire that's
how it is
and uh just want to say uh i just want
to say good night
good night i wrote i i texted
will sasso i go [__] racist and he
goes hey [__] you i go
i go you started this whole thing it's i
don't i don't
the the funny thing that most people
feel is like i think
overall this is positive in the long run
because because
the protests are just as many white
people black people there everybody's
like hey
color hey this slow torture of a man in
broad daylight no
i don't give a [__] like i keep seeing
these memes about like he did this
you know back then doesn't i don't give
a [__] you're talking about the slow
torture of a man in broad daylight
and that's it and and the death the
murderer
happens all the time this one's just
happening but the problem is
is these looters who are the one percent
of the protesters that are damaging
every city they can find and
doing all this stuff that that they're
white i'm sorry no they're
that's not fair but that's not fair i
don't like computer no it's not all just
white and antifa that's not fair
that's true you're giving antifa too
much credit yeah a lot of those yes dude
black looters
a lot of those people are people who are
looting who you know 40 million people
are
unemployed yeah who and then you stick
well the mayor the mayor of atlanta said
you know and and killer mike said you
want to make
a difference fix it keep don't burn your
own house down
sign up a register go to the census so
they know who you are and where you are
yeah that's the long game people on
action now
yes people actually now the other thing
is is uh
you know the looters are you know it's
it's 99
of the media coverage and i think
media's the enemy of the state
you look at the the coverage that
they're posting you know there's been
way more positive and
and friendly 100 peaceful protests
there's been looters but these looters
the one percent
are painting the narrative so everyone
thinks this is the you know the world's
on fire it's not
yeah the other thing is the other
positive the other positive is that
policing in 2015 they were like we they
had a
was still a problem but they had a major
problem i think something like a hundred
unarmed black men were killed and we
know the stories
and some of the stories we don't know
about and in 2019 it was nine it's been
a better there's been a dramatic
decrease
so it is like uh because they
diversified police forces there are a
lot more black cops and
so so it there has been progress made so
you shouldn't feel
heavy-hearted there's still work to be
done there's progress for sure yeah
i mean it does feel like that we've
never been more divided and i woke up
super bummed and my beloved belt podcast
sucked dude i was depressed i felt like
crying a couple of times
oh dude i was crying at the end of my
set my final set saturday you should
have
i i swear to god i was trying not to i
was trying not to cry
yeah well there was that when i was in
the airport there's a little uh
black girl so [__] cute playing
soccer with her dad
and i was just sitting there and i was
missing my kid she kicked towards me and
goes wanna play
dude i started tearing up i mean the dad
was like i'm like what the [__] is wrong
with dude [__] just like
i know everything going on she kicked
this little bongos wanna play
she's like three i'm like [__] do i ever
let's do it i know and then i scored
seven goals dude you can't do that dude
yeah get better
yes you can't talk trash to us you just
want to play soccer man
you can't take that white girl i went
you're the problem
and you kicked the ball in her face yes
and then you started you started a riot
yeah and the the airport caught on fire
that's besides the point
um yeah man houston was great though
oh [__] we had such a blast in houston
yeah well
you know what you have you have a cop
problem uh
uh most of the cops in the world are
most of the cops are
fantastic they're fantastic yeah once
they have a very hard job they have
they have a very hard job they do a
great job you are always going to have
i'm sorry to say you're always going to
have
[__] in every business and you're
going to have murderers in every
business they're going to [__] things up
for the
did you post our video finally yeah i
did
yeah yep yep yeah baby
not bad back to normal it was so cool
i felt i had energy all weekend like
i've never had i just was like
well we went after that we went to this
place called fabians and we did some
[__] dancing
uh well i did i'm a salsa dancer i
smoked hookah and watched it well leave
it leave it to latin you only have one
leave it to latin people no no i'm a
beautiful dancer leave it to that
leave it to latin people who are like
everything is burning and they're just
like
the party goes on motherboard it was
packed i was just i felt like i was
everything was normal again it was crazy
uh was interested in chicago
on friday when the protests start so
i would leave i like to get to the the
venue early and brian likes to go a
little later you know brian's a vet i
like to get there early and cover my p's
and q's and whatever
fabian's there it is latin flavors so
we're getting ready to go and i hear all
i see
not line probably 20 cop cars fly past
this i'm like what the [__] is going on
i'm not on social media that much
anymore i'm like what is going on i see
all this stuff happening
and i look down the street and it's the
protesters and i see three tanks
and i look into it no wonder you text me
you go i was taking a nap oh i was
scared i went b
we got to get out he woke brennan woke
me up i'm napping i'm like you know it's
like i'm supposed to be
what was it like seven it's supposed to
be it starts at 7 30 but i'm taking my
long little nappy poo
and you were like we got to get out yeah
other because i talked to when the cops
go what's going on these protests are
like oh [__]
because they're going to start
barricading everywhere around here so i
go damn i have a shot at seven years you
better get going
because you're not gonna be able to get
back in for a while damn so that sounds
like dude we gotta get the [__] out and
then we should just stay in a hotel
not i packed my survival bag you do i
had my flares
i told jj jacobs what would i do about
my contacts i went
we'll go to cvs and get you the juice to
put them in dude
i'm not gonna [__] come back here
like zombieland and figure it out
yeah that's the thing
[Music]
it's a vulnerable feeling venice man i
just heard because i live right near the
fire house in venice
and uh reflected the firehouse no they
just kept the engines just kept coming
out
oh racist i thought you meant the
restaurant the fire no you see those
trucks come through and you're just like
damn
well yeah there's a curfew today in
santa monica supposed to be at one
but yeah and four for working people
yeah no
one is for businesses and four for
everybody else oh gotcha wow
by the way i was i was not a fan of the
shutdown i'm a fan of curfews
when shit's out of control yeah because
you know these antifa and these other
riders and looters what they're doing
they're they're camouflaging themselves
within the peaceful protesters
hijacking regular people so you can't
it's harder to figure out what's going
on well
with curfew though no one's out you can
kind of single them out this black woman
was like uh watching these two white
kids
maybe antifa and they're like they were
spray-painting black lives matter
on this storefront she was like hey hey
we're not here to cause vandalism i'm
here to [__] protest
you guys are hijacking this and she said
this isn't us they're going to blame us
it was pretty [__] i was like but
again that's why you can't let these
riots paint the narrative what's going
on and
and mask what really you know is the
problem with the judicial system and
black people and all that
yes it's a real problem so somebody
martin luther king said rioting is a
reaction it is not a response
and and he said martin luther king i was
very i'll find the quote but it was
really interesting about how
it when you riot and you destroy in
inherent is that in that is defeat
and is not something that you're going
to change oh did you see our boy eddie
bravo's jim
yeah you want to ruin your day yeah our
good friend eddie jim
destroyed set on fire yeah
unusable i mean there's insurance and
stuff and we'll start gofundme for him
but still
i'll tell you what it's a lot you know
when you see the riots in chicago
and new york you know obviously i love
new york i love chicago but when it's
not in your
hometown or not places you know you're
like god that's terrible but you kind of
move on
but then when you're watching the news
like well hold up that's that's main
street
well we're right by the well i go to i
eat lunch there oh well that's run
yeah oh but box and burn well that's
ruined but oh that's ruined you're like
holy [__] yeah
it's very it hits home like anything
else
but uh but at least we got to do what we
do and make people laugh
yeah how about antifa said let's take it
to the neighborhoods because they got
kicked off social media it's like oh
jesus well here's what's interesting to
me all my
all my very anti-gun liberal friends
i've had three phone calls
not all but three phone calls and
they're all like um
do you uh uh do you have where can i get
guns and do you have a gun and uh can i
call you and i'm like there you go
i [__] up dude because i got home
yesterday and i saw everything going on
and i turned on the news to watch you
know santa monica i'm firing them doing
their [__] thing
and uh i didn't think tiger's paying
attention was playing with his toys
and then uh he's tr he wants to go to
bed and he's all scared like are you
scared dude
he starts talking about you know the
rise you know are they going to come
here i'm like oh [__]
then you can't sleep you got kids too
and then he goes pop i've been shaking
my bed all night
come on get in bed oh it was a long
night dude i [__] up
[__] i didn't think he was paying
attention they paid attention they pay
attention my kids same way
yeah my kid's same way you know
so hopefully you know my father-in-law
is a cop man and
well antifa's been labeled a terrorist
organization or was going to be
and what that means which which people
are like oh it's state is distracting
away from what to do well
say what you want by antifa but what
happened i don't mean it right no
it's the same thing that we did with the
when we had a mafia prompt
is when they make you know those
terrorist laws and people it's not that
big
no it's a big deal because if you're not
all the way in on antifa
and you get caught and you're part of
that going to prison for 40 years yeah
you're looking at you're looking at
federal crimes and
that's when they started that's how they
got the the mob to snitch because they
went
well well you know you can get 40 years
now and you get caught up in the ricoh
act as well so yeah it's a nightmare
if you're caught with with people who
are in antifa it you can be cautious i
know we've
kind of been on trump's nuts a little
bit i don't like to get too political
been on his nuts a little bit during
corona which i've appreciated for and
open up the
state and stuff like that forget karana
he's doing who gives a [__]
again i'll lick your face [__] mask but
and with this all this going on
i would like my present come out and
take some leadership and speak on this
oh why because he came out and said when
the looting starts the shooting starts
which was what
which is original which is what the
chief of police in 1968
said in miami when people were
protesting civil rights and he said if
they want to see
police brutality they haven't seen
anything yet that was a racist
police chief white police chief in miami
and the problem is when your
president in 2020 [__] quotes that
you're defining this dude you're using
you're using
even white people about using a language
from 1968 that a racist police chief
used
think of a [__] better quote dude not
so original
he said at first it wasn't bad he goes
there these looters are dishonoring the
memory of
george floyd i won't let that happen can
you stop there
can you not say you know and do you have
to tag it with when the looting
starts the shooting starts what
everybody like killer mike and everybody
who's a [__]
black leader knows exactly what that
means
you can't do that you're the the tim
waltz told me that the military is with
him all the way any difficulty
will assume control but when the looting
starts the shooting starts
taken from what what's his name walter
harold what's the [__] is this the chief
of police in 196 either way though
well you can't say that you cannot i
want my
yeah i want the leader of the free world
to come out and at least try to come up
with an eloquent way to
yeah but bubba he's a law and order
president meaning
look al sharpton was very very clear on
this al sharpton said
you guys have to be careful not to
destroy your neighborhoods because
what happens is you will def
it's a self-defeating prophecy in the
sixth in where after martin luther king
was was assassinated
um there were there was looting and
rioting and and al sharpton was 13 years
old
and and what happened was people got
scared and they voted in a law and
ordered president and that was
president nixon you have to be careful
because sometimes when you are
protesting and destroying things people
get scared they want order
and you are going to it's a
self-defeating prophecy so
again this is not lost on the mass
majority of especially black protesters
who are
protesting peacefully so you know it's
it's it's hard man it's fi this is an
emotional catharsis for a lot of people
it's [__] hard it's just hard man uh
you know
uh yeah let's move on dude yeah best we
can
uh yeah fun you have fun and you use we
had
truth barbecue those are my boys hey
you're welcome hey boys kind of
connected
uh thank you for that i smelled now i
smelled like smoke the whole day the
whole time because
we went to the smoke let me send you in
the video yeah we're
trying to be cool and do a funny video
and we had the smoke
we couldn't get through it because the
smoke yeah and then they they picked up
our meal
thank you to smoke to truth to truth
barbecue
truth bar and then uh butcher dude
bnb butchers another again uh what the
[__] uh
what's his name whiskey pete no not
whiskey p took us chris took us
but it was also the guy who um was the
manager there who bought us dinner
he was awesome i can't believe him
forget his name it's a it's a
it's a biblical name it's like zacharias
or something like that or tobias i don't
remember
and that food was something else being
me butchered that that that's that's
probably the best steak i've ever had
man
oh that's that place was no how about
the yeah
that pork belly with [__] blue cheese
whoo
our boy jeremiah but jeremiah jeremiah
butler there it is
i'm from alaska in spokane oh wow
likes his whiskey likes his whiskey
casper you're my butler we learned some
[__] about whiskey too
you learn some sugar cask strength
whiskey you gotta educate a little
whiskey yes i did
that blends that that cask strength and
the 17 year old cast grant that you
can't get in the united states your boy
finished it a little bigger than a hand
grenade that [__] was at that
legion huh you don't need your lids done
[Music]
you can't see my eyes although i can't
see yours either so yeah but i'm smiling
i got a fat face
you're not smiling we're going to trim
your face up a little bit and we're
going to take my eyes up that's all
we're going to do
if you can zoom in on the bottle i had
chin that's a ginger 115 year old ginger
drinking that ginger brandy oh dude
kaufman's oh it's nice i have a question
yeah you know what i'm going to ask
no from 1905
you don't think it is i'm just saying i
know you bought it
i know i know chris no i know chris
bought it oh you spent that
pretty penny on that about a grand on
that oh more than that papa i just for
me i'm always like
1905 huh you don't think it's from 1905
i
think it's possible it's not oh wow
you're a hater i think it's
the same one who hate on rogan's samurai
sword yes
and you got one whiskey head from the
civil war with the label on it
where is that when's that samurai sword
from 1500s
yeah look at my hands look at my hands
600 years distracting because you're
like 700 years old you don't think so
seven hundred don't think people have it
though i just been to museums i've seen
the no you don't you don't think there's
old whiskey out there
what about the wines and [__] you just
old wines there's old wines there's
little mines but they
whiskey's easier than it's like red when
you see it and i've also seen the labels
of really old ones i've seen the labels
of really old ones do that
look at the cork like i told it looks
like your nose that cork was sold
but my nose is only 50 years old i know
that's why that
looked worse yeah click on the video
though this is what this is mean like
i hate you're going bad on whiskey i'm
not even i'm not and i'm gonna
no chris believes that he reached out to
you no chris belie i love chris
chris believes it he almost compete
the whiskey podcast so this so this is
us at truth barbecue
in the smokers and hold on it's 106
degree in there
and it was so hot and they're showing us
how it's done me and brian go this will
be fun let's make a video watch how this
video goes
there's a reason why i didn't post
barbecue right
and we're basically saying what they
said to us when they give us the tour
yeah
i'm like let's make this funny um it was
it was impossibly hot
yeah it was so hot and they work in that
one it's 130 degrees and they go this
ain't nothing man i've seen it get up to
1 30 in here
we've been working all morning all
morning this month
just so it's a feel yeah it's the feel
and the stuff
[Music]
couldn't get through it the smoke you
can't see the smoke in there but if
you're if you're going to do barbecue
you're not i don't think you get better
barbecue than drink
i really don't i don't think you get
better than that and i'm not a barbecue
fan was that
you don't like barbecue well after
barbecue i always feel like i ate way
too much ice cream and
chocolate like it's so heavy no it's
heavier than that it's good so heavy
i like taking that potato bread and the
brisket and putting the uh
bark sauce on top that's fair and then
next door is voodoo donuts
that's fair too how about how about our
blankets just trying to get us to [__]
our pants yep how about malik how about
our boy malik you love molly right now
isn't he the best nice text this morning
the best summer great takes one the
nicest guy
now i told him he was opening for us in
arizona oh you did yeah
did you have chappelle's from there oh
don't use both of them because tim's not
coming
tim's not coming oh we use both of them
did not tell you this no
i have ct brian yesterday he told me he
can't make it
well then we're using chappelle and
malik yes i love it
i love that those guys are great max
molex we'll have an african-american
portion of our show and then the
caucasian portion of our show
yes let's sprinkle ebony and ivory kids
he's so funny how great is malik
he's such a nice guy and how funny is
that [__] so funny
i'm telling you nobody works harder
nobody works harder well hold my bear
but he's such a nice guy
i know he's such a good guy now
now you gave a little taste of wrestling
well hold now hold on now hold on here
before i was taught me and i were tired
i think it was friday night
so i go you know what wakes me up is
when if i can just pummel i couldn't
believe it no no that's not what you
said
hold on i'm i'm he's getting ready to go
out on stage
and where when was it was it saturday or
friday friday night
and you know late show friday night your
your energy's a little and brennan just
goes i want to wrestle
i was so tired i'm in bed by nine yeah
and you go let's do a little wrestling
and we started to wrestle
now i've been working under hooks and
stuff like that didn't really work on me
because you put your head
in my chin i gave you the same car yeah
and then you got and then i i tried
i said do you wanna see the khabib game
plan and i did i'd give him a breakdown
a physical breakdown of how khabib he
gets his opponents to the floor and then
what he does when you get you caught my
hips you brought my hips
in and then you started to snake me
slowly like an anaconda does you're done
your post
you took my post down and then you were
kind of lightly punching me in the face
and the head and
i took your legs away like khabib does i
said now and i i said you're against the
wall now this is a cage
yeah and i said now i'm gonna let you
work to get up brian work to get up yeah
i took
my wrist control like khabib and then
you you wrapped my legs that was not fun
either that's what khabib does
yeah i gave you the complete that's a
special that's a khabib special sell
that
i could sell you gave me the khabib
special i didn't like it
and then because then alec comes in
who's been a boxer since he was seven
comes out of a wild card and floyd
mayweather's camp
and he's he's wiry though you felt his
strength a little bit when you
wiring yeah why aren't you not strong
compared to brendan shaw
no
i thought you were being serious a
little bit you were like oh he's strong
and i thought
maybe brenda will have a little trouble
then i'm
in the big boy then the big boy you made
me do it too
and molly couldn't like get your hands
on him yeah let's do this i'm like
all right well malik wanted a feel
because now he's in as a pure boxer he's
into mma and he wanted to feel what it's
like
to get in the clutches of a heavyweight
and he didn't understand what's going on
you got him in the fl
fluke choke oh no because he grabbed my
neck and i said you're going to keep
that goes i've seen this on ufc i went
okay hang on to it that's great he goes
am i doing right go yeah man keep
squeezing as hard as you can
jump to the side and then i go i'm gonna
go to the side you still got it goes i
it feels pretty i go yeah tighten it up
tightness
get tight niven flew choking me this
what the [__] he didn't know what was
going on because i didn't know what was
happening because that was [__] up
he was talking to me we talked this
morning he was talking to me about it oh
really yeah he goes i don't know what
the [__] that was
no that's not that's that's that's you
got caught you got caught up in
you know he's a handsome guy too
handsome guy
the ladies he's looking at
so stevie blue eyes is with us and
molek's friend is with us
i don't give his name away he's another
great guy or a great boy guy
great comic but he's in the room and he
goes hey man uh because steve was
talking about how much money him and his
girl making his girl's the number one
porno star in the world
uh aniston um he was talking about how
much they make on onlyfans.com so
you know he threw around numbers next
day our friend goes hey stevie
i was talking to my girl man and uh you
know we're thinking about doing that
only fancy that's how much you guys
bring on i go
well you know these girls like the porn
star that's one of the reasons it's not
because the biggest porn star in the
world
because they don't make money because
stevie has a great dick but you can use
any dead yes
any any dick will work yes but then
she's just generous enough to give
stevie a cut here's all we're seeing do
i go oh yeah your girl's baggage does
she bang and do she like this i went
well let me see i'll tell you which one
you make
he shows he shows me a video i go and
molly got the joke but everyone else
thought it was just she's let me just
describe it she's got a bowl cut she's a
rather
heavy-sensitive chinese heavyset asian
woman it's all
good chinese pigtails where the prison
tattoo prison tattoo goes chess and i go
and i go oh damn i go you do so you're
gonna make no money if you show all this
but what you can do is just her feet
you do her feet jacking off molly you
have to choke
we were laughing so hard because he goes
he was dead he goes you think man
i go dude just feet though don't show
the face nothing else
he goes yeah you right you right man
that's a good idea maulik and steve were
laughing so much you know it was
yeah it was pretty crazy yeah he wasn't
aware of how the porn world works
you can't just use your girl or that his
girls door doorly explore it through in
france
there are there were issues there's a
there's a market for everyone but
that nicole tends to be the big money
she's a superstar yes she is yeah she's
the superstar
[Music]
hopefully you drove your uh paul newman
uh car down to the riot in santa monica
because they'll like that
what is the one thing you don't have a
problem with
is steaks you know it's a great gift
father's day send your dad steaks i know
it sounds crazy but i'm talking about
almost
all my god 100 american grain finished
beef naturally aged at least 21 days for
the ultimate in tenderness juiciness
flavor they offer a variety of options
you got you got
steaks chicken pork burgers you got
french you got uh
hot dogs hot dogs they sent me a bunch
of hot dogs
um it's the perfect father's day gift
because dad wants steak
and it's kind of crazy right it's like i
got you a whole box of steak
coffee cup i know gift card don't do
that
bacon by the way omaha steaks can help
you find the best gift for your dad we
talking about that meat down his throat
and it's every everyone is flash frozen
so so it's vacuum sealed
it's fresh safely in a cooler with dry
ice
stays ready to cook in the freezer for
months yes get it right now
the special father's day gift
is offering you guys
go to omahastakes.com and enter the code
fighter into the search bar
you see all the great options available
many uh that include free shipping and a
free one pound package of their
perfectly cured
incredibly f thick applewood smoked
steak cut
bacon baby bacon man the best bacon
it's delicious make father's day simple
this year send dad the gift he really
wants
talking about meat in his mouth
perfectly aged omaha steaks and get free
shipping
free steak cut bacon with select
packages visit omahasteak.com type
fighter in the search bar to shop for
father's day right now
now i wish i could show everybody what
i'm working with
downstairs because i'm so escaped that's
cool i'm just so scared
you're talking about below but they're
actually they're not like the weed
whacker
my friend blue's son yeah loki
okay the other day i go hey loki you're
i can see all the hair on your nose
he goes it's quarantined i haven't had
time to trip i'm like there's no excuse
it's guy code i i'm going to send him
the weed whacker i'm going to send my
dad my father
my father just doesn't believe in
trimming his nostril hair i'm like i'm
trying to eat
put up your nose use the weed whacker
use a 9000 rpm motor powered 360 degree
rotary
dual blade system you're not going to
cut your nose the battery lasts up to 90
minutes
it's unbelievable it's a telescope oh
god
remember when i told uh lex to trim his
nose hair and he started pulling him out
i was like dude disgusting yeah it's
time to upgrade
it's time to upgrade your mansion i've
called out two of my friends yeah man
manscaped is making whacking your weeds
there you go a time
look forward to delivering maximum
confidence while providing hygiene
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code fighterwwmanscape.com that's
fighter wwsn for weed whacker
thank you manscape for keeping our pubes
trimmed our hairs and our holes looking
nice
but but man escaped we did a poll and
they asked a bunch of women
and 79 percent of them said long nose
hair is a major turnoff guys too man you
can't be my
i can't talk to you no if you have long
nose hair get it together
and don't connect to your mustache
[__] eyebrows when your eyebrows are
all over guys and i can see your nose
here
hey hey i'm trying to eat bro get 20
off and free shipping with code fighter
www.manscape.com
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use code fighter ww
what are you waiting for go whack your
freaking nose here
whack your weeds in chaos in chaos adam
we need you here we need your voice
what's going on uh
it's crazy times i'm doing good uh i
just did my podcast and drove on in from
uh
are you driving with any weaponry or
flares in your car or did you just rely
on your engine
my hands are weapons that's true and my
my personal style
is my flair that's [__] a great
answer dude
i wonder if these writers would know if
you drove your paul newman right
i wonder if they're like we don't know
what that is the newman
stuff is so unstreetable like it's so
low like it it shoots fire i
i mean have you ever seen it if you see
pictures of
me driving a paul newman race car you'll
see
fire coming out of the exhaust pipe oh
yeah it's not street legal
no it's it's a it's a cage it's a cage
with fiberglass
hanging off that's like slicks you know
everyone always says how fast
does it go and it would depend how you
geared it and what the track was but
it's really about lap times like
racing is all about lap times it's not
really about speed or top speed because
these are
road courses so yeah like that's a
newman 935
um so what would that go from zero to 60
if you is that
it doesn't really count in those race
cars it's not it's not zero to six
it's quick it would probably be in the
threes on a 9 35
but it's more kind of about the road
course like it's rights and lefts and
changes of elevations and so when you're
doing that
what speed are you averaging would you
say well like i just did a race
i did a professional trans am race i
drove a a
corvette c7r at willow springs
and it was a professional trans am race
that i entered
a couple years ago and
willow springs it's a professional it's
a it's a real corvette it's yeah it's
that corvette the upper left
willow springs is two and a half miles
around
and the guy who was sitting on the pole
of that race
did a 117. so he did
two and a half miles in in once in a
minute and 17 seconds
i was probably a minute and 20 seconds
so actually there's footage of that car
if you type it in and you'll see the
speedo that car has a
digital speedo and it probably gets up
to like
161 on the front straight
and gets up to probably top one one yeah
like 158 or so
where do you know are you on the back in
this case i
am a professional race car driver this
is
what it looks like inside that car jesus
and and how long did it take you to get
to this level like and
not that long i got a i got a drivers i
got a professional driver's license our
vintage driver's license not
i don't know 10 years ago or something
like that but anyway that's it's an
expensive hobby
what it looks like inside the car that
car that's 50 grand
if you want to run that car 50 grand
what do you mean for
the car yeah the car i didn't pay it but
the car comes in
the car comes in there's one that says
there's like one that's like three and a
half minutes long and it'll
show the the speedometer it'll show the
speeds but
it's expensive the car comes in from
florida they have a whole bunch of
attacks and
and blah blah blah yeah it's probably
that one are you b
you're into race car driving but
different cars different i'm my mine's
more
yeah i'm not into like the the race i i
appreciate it and i i know a little bit
about it but
uh for like my car and stuff like i
don't race like j
races jerry going attract but not like
adam he's doing like street cars
you don't you're not into you're not
into the newer cars adam
uh i i like i like newer cars
but you'll see you'll see what this car
does on cold tires this is just a
practice what's your car do on that
track
against these cars well there's a
million tracks
so for for for like cars like mine the
nuremburger
in germany is where the herberg ring
yeah the nurburgring is what they test
on so
the gt2 rs set the record my car
and then lamborghini got their
pronounced lamborghini yep
and they then they beat it and then
porsche went cool story
sent the gt2 rs to uh mr which
did some fine tuning and they took the
record again so it's the but that those
are street cars yeah
he's car you can't his cars aren't
straight gotcha okay but that's what
every everyone goes for the fast laps so
this
this car is going 158 into a turn into
long
long term holy [__] that's fast yeah
it's
it's it's a fast it's not pretty fast
you just piss yourself they do a whole
uh
he just they do a whole thing where
they're like time you getting out of the
car and
into the car and all this kind of junk
in case you catch on fire and stuff
you have a whole pit team there too well
you don't
in a race like this you wouldn't do a
pit stop what you would do
is you'd have a crew and a semi and they
would set the car up so it's like you
come back
after practice or after qualifying and
they would
dial in all the stuff they take the tire
temps spring rates they hook the
computer up to it they'd
see if they put more down force in the
tail
and mess around with some geometry and
the suspension and stuff and then you
just go out
that way somebody who's a boxer with
hands that are deadly
is race car driving a [__] skill
or a sport or both uh
it's nowhere near as grueling as
boxing or mma or you know maybe even
tennis or golf or something it's not
it's it's not physically demanding what
it does
is it it it's physically sort of
commanding
it commands your attention so
and you don't realize what a weird
calorie burn
your attention is like you don't realize
you turn your attention
on and off all the time so you kind of
go like let me check a text or what's
that on cnn and then you turn it off and
then you come back on
and then you turn it off and so like
when you're
boxing or playing football or something
like that it's like you got your
attention and then there's a moment
where you go okay we go back to a huddle
like i don't have to be this is a weird
full-time
this is two hours of pure attention it's
two hours the races
yeah this is [__] this this was a 40
lap race it was probably in the car
about two hours so it's just
full attention this at intensity for two
hours
so what you what ends up happening is
you get out of the car
and you haven't moved but your fire suit
is like sweat you sweat all the way
through because you're
you're bolted in in the six-way harness
and you're not lifting anything or doing
anything
it's just crazy well mathematicians and
scientists and einstein talked about
this like
you when you are thinking about a
problem
over a prolonged period of time you
actually burn calories you
you you your brain uses a lot of energy
yeah einstein was shredding
he was right i got some pictures of him
bring out my size shirt like
[__] there's a picture of eyes that were
no shirt on
yeah that's what i always say about
that's
well there you go surprisingly there's
pictures with his shirt off
i was surprised i think we fine i didn't
think we'd find one holy [__]
that's a that's he's a thickie he's in
the thick boy bike club adam t i used
needs a bike though um did you ever
think about getting like the f1 racing
no i mean you got to start go-karting
four like you got to start go go karting
at four
sena like lewis hamilton's the you know
he's the number one rates in the world
most paid i think athlete in the world
now
but he started i mean oh yeah yeah he's
there those radios him he's
oh yeah four on this little cart going
you have to
start it for you can't be over
and fifty five pounds and and do that
true oh yeah i think daniel ricardo my
boy he's he's
bigger look how big i think he's six two
maybe he is
he's longer but i guarantee he doesn't
get in that car over 160 160
live why why just you can't have the
heat
in in a in a in a danny ricardo's 143.
five seven he's he seems like a giant
compared
to the rest of the guys out there who's
the number one guy
the lewis hampton but ricardo's a stock
what is
the point oh yeah he's my boy the point
is is in a world that's separated by
thousands of a second you putting an
extra 25
pounds in your car of weight that's like
swimming it's a huge deal
olympic swimming is so weird it's like
so literally like they'll trim their
fingernails
i mean they keep their fingers he's five
nine
150. the uh also
well he's got a couple of piercings so i
think
hoops count you're right i don't know is
it weird when a guy gets more than like
three on one ears
yeah it's tough you know also you have
to make 100 million dollars a year which
he does but but by the way you're the f1
champ you don't think you're going to
get your [__] sucked after the race like
do you think that chicks you think the
pit girl who works
for pepsi is going to be like i'm sorry
where are the hoops
oh i don't care about the trophy where's
the who
that's a good looking [__] right
there yo you want to talk about someone
jesus
you know we talk about pivot and you
talk about these these athletes and
celebrities that had hair transplant
have you ever seen his he had a hair
transplant oh bubba
dude no one talks about it the best of
all time i don't think she had
no here oh hello yeah wow
there's cornrows now what are we doing
how the [__] did he get i'd love
cornrows it's 100 million dollars a year
they're gonna figure it out get his hair
i
to know i want to get some of that [__]
isn't that crazy
you spend your entire career wearing a
full face helmet really do you have to
worry that much about your hair yeah
like he's the time he'll figure out
well he looks a lot better do you have a
career where as soon as the helmet comes
off somebody puts a hat on
you that's a suit that's true some
european petro company that goes on your
head like
there's not a lot of scalp time with
these guys you're right
you haven't been at the same barbershop
other time with both your boss i was
gonna say i'm impressed with this
[__]
go that one way as a cornrows that's him
that's him currently that's him now
what the [__] bro dude i'd love to be
him
well i'd love to get a nose ring but i
can't pull that off i'd love to have a
hand tattoo
this guy's got it all down to a science
who's his stylist
he's he's super i mean he's dating uh
kendall jenner he dates the only daniel
jenner the only the
hottie i mean he's the lebron james of
the
f1 world jesus christ he's a i mean he
makes more money than one brother he's a
handsome guy
yeah so anyway you start carding at four
and you get the hair transplant at 29.
that's basically that's your arc as an
f1 drive i don't think people realize
like those f1 drivers you know it's big
internationally
real big not too big here jay loves it
jace you know
he goes all over the count though yeah
formula one right there
in europe it's so big in europe it's
such a difference it never caught on
here
it's so [__] big in europe is a big
hero
8500 is huge i've been a couple times
it's a crazy event they're
they're also f1 is getting big
at circuit of the americas at uh austin
or uh coda they call it whatever they
have an f1 track there and it's like
kind of catching on
it's more expensive than anything else
isn't it yes oh yeah it's it's the cars
look like indy cars but they're probably
ten times the people
i watched senna that documentary i had
no idea that
it's a team of scientists engineers
whatever they are
i mean it's the craziest [__] i've ever
seen who's that mercedes red bull
there's some big boys
yeah you gotta know you race for a big
company like that yeah well yeah but
it's millions and millions of dollars
ten point five have you ever seen how
much the like just the engine cost 10.5
million dollars for an engine that's the
crazy [__] i've ever heard
yeah car engine yeah oh my god and they
rebuild everything they do this
that's why my boy daniel ricardo you
know he doesn't race with the best teams
and he still gets good
track times that's why everyone loves it
oh wow because he had a different car he
probably won the goddamn thing yeah yeah
yeah i used to like him when i thought
he was six too me too
now i know he's five seven i don't like
him anymore you can just kind of bully
him
and then you just walk up to it listen
you're great but i still tower over you
so i win
yeah next time my wife says oh yeah
danny ricardo says i'll go [__] that guy
yeah i used to be six too they do call
him the honey badger though yeah
oh they do yeah when rogan was younger
rogan uh
rogan's i know rogan for 25 years way
before he was married and rogan's got a
piece on him i i know this
and uh you see i remember this he was
like 28 or something some girl he's like
yeah you dating him yeah bigger dick
than me
she goes doesn't have a big dick in here
he goes then i win
it was [__] great he said i win
i wonder maybe us guys
with the full heads of hair maybe we
should
hate the guys the pivons of the world
who've had the hair restoration like
chicks
with a nice rack hate the fake tit
chicks because it's like hey man you've
just
even the [__] playing field and it's
like i didn't get a lot of advantages
you know from my my gene pool to get
laid but i do have a full [__] se
got that full screen alec give me that
at least yeah i have plenty of follicles
uh up on my up on my dome but now you
guys have surgically
even the [__] sticking out well
that's how i feel about when black
people are protesting and
a bunch of white kids with masks are
like black lives matter and like that
and like
hey mother do you have to take that from
us too right you know
it's like stop annexing yeah with my
hair you got brought up on here
who are we talking about uh with adam
about where he got started
oh with uh jimmy kimmel right yeah yeah
but who who are we talking about that
with
uh michael's michael oh mike yeah psycho
micah yes
yeah or psycho mike there was a psycho
michael who's in like a social
distortion or something there's a
punk band that's got a psychic i always
said about i always said about adam i
said i
watched him do an hour of improv on
stage at the irvine improv i watched him
take suggestions and do fully formed
bits
fully formed like hilarious bits
on everything the audience gave him and
i came up to you afterwards and i go
you're the best in the world at
improving
at it at taking a topic and improving
off it and he goes no i don't know i go
somebody's got to be you're the guy it's
the greatest first off you're the
opposite of my parents
what do you think of me what's that son
uh
no so i i always remember this
compliment and it's it's
interesting and thank you it's
interesting to me because
sometimes jimmy will go like oh
you know he'll go like oh you know
george clooney and i'll go i don't know
george because i never met john and then
he'll go no
remember we met him he said he was a big
fan of the man show and i was like oh i
don't remember that like i'll block
out a lot of positivity your compliment
sticks it totally stuck and it's it's
because
he gave the compliment and i was like uh
a pitcher like waving off the catcher
sign like
no no no no just like yeah you may be
one of the most tell yeah
no no no no i'm waving it off so i
started waving it off
and brian like stopped and he went well
somebody's got to be the best and i'm
like
okay that works well not only that i
also told you i know the difference
i'm qualified to make that i'm qualified
i'm as qualified as anybody on the
planet to say
that i know the difference i'm right and
that's the way it is well i will
take it yeah so congratulations thank
you man
you were talking about because uh psycho
mike uh mike catherwood was saying
uh how it's such a bummer that there's
no you know kevin b and all that's
getting canceled he's talking about
how you got your start with jimmy kimmel
was on there
and you were helping him get ready for
some like boxing competition is that
right
yeah it's a and then they would bring
you in they're like dude this guy's
hilarious and smart as [__] why isn't he
doing this why are we doing this
it should be i don't know something for
the kids listening um i was like
i i i wasn't a highly motivated guy i
was kind of a [__] up i was a bad
student
i didn't go to college i hung around
with sort of [__] ups from the valley we
clean carpets and work construction and
stuff like that
and i was like the whole story is kind
of
kind of interesting in that i gave
myself this
timeline i was like by the time you're
30 you got to be doing
something like something i i wasn't
thinking about
famous tv how old were you when you made
that
i was like i was like 21 or 22.
give yourself a lot of time i did i i
did that's for sanity
by the time you're 20 40. that's [__]
patience yeah by the time you get to
clint eastwood's current age
you my friend no i was like i did
i i did like i was i was totally
realistic about it like i was like
21 living with these you know three
dudes in a one bedroom
in north hollywood you know no air
crappy apartment
everyone just worked construction drove
a pickup truck you know
nothing like you know drinking shaffer
beer on the weekends and
ripping bong loads and trying to get
laid and everything no insurance
no parents had no money no no nothing i
didn't have car insurance i didn't have
anything
and i was like i was like sitting around
like watching all these idiots
get high all day and sort of just
working for the weekend you know get
your paycheck
nine bucks an hour you know go out to
the lake or whatever
and and i was like 21 or 22 and i was
like how's this going to end like
how are you ever going to get a house i
love cars
i drive a pickup truck i have to drive a
pickup truck for my job i can't afford a
second car i don't have insurance on my
pickup truck
how could i drive a cool car and
with this lifestyle so i was just like
sitting in my apartment in north
hollywood and i was like
well what else could you do what's a way
you could make money
and i thought you know one way would be
more of what i'm doing like get a
contractor's license
work more hours you know get 15 bucks an
hour you know
and and the other thought was like well
what else are you good at like what
could you do
and i was a [__] student so i knew oh
you're not going to be an attorney or a
doctor
or work in this capacity or that
capacity i really couldn't like fill out
paperwork and work
in a corporate world i was like well
you're funny
you got a sense of humor that's it
that's all all we know about you
is you're good with your hands and and
then you're funny
and i don't know what funny means i
don't know what to do with funny but
at least you have that so i was like all
right you now have
nine years until you're 30.
until you're 30. well i i figured out
like i was like
when you're 20 you can do whatever you
want like you're not a loser
no if you meet a guy and he doesn't own
a home 23
or he doesn't have a second car he's his
career's not taken off and he's like in
his 20s
yeah but when it starts with a three now
it's time
and by the way that was the old 30. now
you know guys are 50 and they're
[__] finding themselves on the beach
you know
i got a t-shirt company i was thinking
about okay 50 something you have a great
pube dude
maybe you should what multi-piercings on
the right here a lot of hoops you
driving f1
so whenever anybody who's in their 40s
and 50s gets their first tattoo
hey bro it's over so i'm like
sitting there and going okay by the time
you're 30
something and i i it wasn't such a
general goal
well tony robbins would be like we got
to stop you know let's get more specific
we at that time it's like
the floor collapsed of an outhouse and
i'm up to my neck and [__]
and i'm thinking to myself how do i get
out of this and hose myself
off i'm not thinking about surf and turf
in a martini
like i'll go i gotta just get to [__]
terra firma and find a garden hose
so i was like that was the that was my
mindset
like i need a paycheck
i need i want to get paid for christmas
day
you know i mean like in construction
there's no payment whatever
christmas holidays you roll your ankle
playing hoop on a sunday you don't come
in monday
you don't get paid yeah that that i was
like some job
maybe a little security a business card
like
maybe i could write jokes for like a a
greeting card company i could make funny
cards or
or i could be part of someone else's
project and write jokes for them or some
you know just or whatever whatever
whatever works but
it wasn't about being in front of the
camera
or on stage or anything but i didn't
rule that out i was just like whatever
so
i didn't know where to go i didn't know
what to do and i found a friend of mine
whose parents who are like kind of in
the industry a little
and i said what should i do where should
i go
and they said there's a place called the
groundlings and it's on like melrose and
you could go sign up for classes
and i was like okay and i just went it
was 350 bucks for
you know 10 classes i didn't have car
insurance but i was like [__] it
i'll go do that and i did that
and and and everyone in the classroom
martin they went to college and they had
this big vocabulary and
and they all kind of like the teacher
would go all right move upstage and i'd
start walking to the left you know no no
not stage
left stage right they're all like majors
yeah what stage
i like to start following everyone
around and not turning my back like jim
morris into the audience and stuff
and uh eventually i you know did a bunch
of open mics did a ton of
things eventually i was kind of ready
but
i i still had nothing oh we're looking
at
no that's not me in the groundlings
let's see
that's the there is some old probably
old pictures of me from
uh back back in those days
improv troops and stuff like that i
started the acme theater and
blah blah blah you started the album
acme well it wasn't called the acme and
i
ended up building the acme theater and
everything else but anyway so i i'm
a few weeks away from my 30th birthday
and i realized nothing has worked out
like i i still i'm no closer to a job
i got nothing it's it's it's not worked
out like the dream hasn't worked out but
i
do have a job as a boxing coach
at uh it uh god what was it called
uh oh bodies in motion in in pasadena
terrible name i know they had me i built
the gym
i built it out like it was already built
as a structure i just kind of
hung the heavy bags and [__] and then
the guy who worked there said you can
teach class
20 bucks a class right so
i was working there and i would teach
the morning class
and then i would go work as a carpenter
and i was like i don't know a month away
from turning 30 and i was like i was
teaching boxing i was
still working as a carpenter and the
whole comedy thing just
evidently never worked out i had all
this training
yeah but i still wasn't getting paid and
i had nothing
nothing to do and so i was driving my
truck
over uh laurel canyon with my
entertainment unit in the back of it
i've
built somebody back when he'd have the
big tv and pull out drawers or the vhs
rack and everything
and and i hear jimmy kimmel
who's jimmy the sports guy on kevin and
bean
and he's doing the sports and he gets
into an argument like impromptu
with uh michael the maintenance man
who's a you know part of the morning zoo
and they challenge each other to a
boxing match
and and i've listened to k rock my whole
life because i grew up in
los angeles you know and love line and
everything else
and i've never i don't know where the
station is i've never met anybody i
don't know anything like radio is a
weird enigma you know
and they're going all right well we're
go we're having a boxing match and we
need trainers we need equipment and we
need
gyms if you're listening right now you
know and i'm like drive my truck going
i could train one of those guys to box
and you know you've been boxing at this
point i had been
boxing for
i did the golden gloves when i was 19.
and then i'd stuck with it for
probably 10 years at that point and i
was working
as a trainer at a place that was like
you know executive boxing like fitness
yeah
you know but just secretaries and you
know airline pilots and [__] but
but i was a little more hardcore so like
my class was a little more
like box like we had like mike weaver
work there
and the uh weaver triplets worked there
and mike weaver's like a you want to
talk about a physique
show me mike weaver this guy
you want to talk about a brick [__]
house of a heavyweight
from circa you know 1982
or something holy [__] this guy ain't
juicing i mean i knew mike weaver when
he was
i knew mike weaver when he was 45 he was
up still
good god jacked wow that's not steroids
no he's uh you want to talk about just
you want to talk about an incredible
physique
nice guy weaver taught
were taught that i mean look at that
guy's build from like 1978 you know
not so so he had some credit in boxing
so you
just called the station out of the blue
so i get over the hill
it's such a crazy and uh and the weaver
triplets are
floyd lloyd and troy
who were the fighting triplets who were
weavers
half kid brothers or whatever you know
heavyweights they got a lot of half can
out there yeah
so i went over there i can't have ken
those are the so those guys all worked
at the
the fighting triplets get the [__] out
of here those are the triplets
these are the fighting triplets oh r b
man they all worked
yeah yeah they they all worked at bodies
in motion
with me it's a little homoerotic a
little bit
but they're good-looking dudes they're
looking dude they've got that soft
oiled what the [__] out of you but
they're also like they're bodied up i've
seen many pornos like this
have i that looks like you got you
wouldn't be so much you wandered into
the wrong
definitely click on that keep going hot
guys well i mean the owner of the gym
hated me because mike weaver is like an
ex-heavyweight champ and he's got a
bunch of secretaries so he'd just be
walking by like
punch high punch low punch hot it was
like
everyone's standing squared off you know
just
now punch low everything and i'm like oh
what are we doing here like we need to
teach people how to box and he's like no
one wants to learn how to box they want
to burn calories
i got the five dudes who wanted to learn
to box not the hot
secretaries of punching the punch low
but anyway
i get over the hill i get to my client's
house
you know pre-cell phone and i like come
in like could i use your phone
and it's like yeah and i i call kevin
bean
i leave a message i got nothing i keep
calling and leaving messages
there no one calls back i can't get
anything the next day it's like oh we
need trainers we need
their call they're getting them on the
air hey man i'm a trainer oh yeah where
you out of you know
what your qualification i'm like they're
gonna get this dude to train
again jimmy'd only been there like
two months and he was doing jimmy the
sports guy i didn't know who he was but
michael the maintenance man been there
like four years i was like i want to
train
the maintenance man but it didn't matter
and eventually
they wouldn't return my call eventually
like how your goals were so [__]
modest i didn't have anything
i was going to try the maintenance man i
want to see inside the studio that's my
goal i want to see inside the studio
so but it's like a calling to me
so it's interesting yeah eventually i go
[__] it i'm going down there i find out
where the building is it's in burbank's
a commercial building
in burbank and i i go down there and i
have
i'm teaching a 6 30 a.m class
monday wednesday friday whatever it is
so i go down there at like
6 or 5 30 and the whole building's
locked up like you can't get in the
building and then
some guy goes building opens at seven
and i go oh okay i'll come back tomorrow
at seven
and i go back i get a guy to cover my
the second half of my class like i teach
the first half and i run back to burbank
and the building's open and i get into
the buildings like a commercial
building and i go up to the ninth floor
where k rock is but
the suite is closed k rock is like their
business hours are like nine to five
like they go when you pick up your
prize you know you gotta come after nine
o'clock i know kevin and bean are in
the corner somewhere they're in their
studio but there's no receptionist the
doors are locked
so now i'm like standing out by the
elevators
like going what do i do they don't open
for two hours
i gotta like go back and finish my class
i don't know what to do and like as
i'm pacing around the elevators trying
to figure out like do i go home
a guy comes out of the elevator
he has like a key card and he see him
going around like the back like to where
the service entrance or the key card you
know he's going to refill the vending
machine
or drop off something or whatever and
i'm just like i go with him down the
hall i go are you going in
you're going into k rock he's like yeah
i gotta whatever and i go okay
just tell them there's gonna a boxing
guys come down here trainer i get a
trainer i'm gonna be by the elevators
i'll just wait here
but tell them to come out and i don't
know if they're on a break or commercial
break or
who's in there or what you um i just
sit by the elevator and then like 15
minutes later
jimmy just comes around just comes down
the hall just comes walking down the
hall
and he just goes hey you you're the
boxing guy
and i go yeah i'm the boxing trainer he
goes okay
and i go okay and he goes all right i go
you want me to be your boxing coach and
he's like okay
i go okay when do you want to start he
goes today
and i go okay let's start today and he
goes okay well i gotta go back in
like finish the job
destiny dude and he goes how about i go
when can you meet me is it
noon i go okay noon body's in motion
pasadena i'll be like at the
parking structure across the street i'll
give them the address because okay see
you then
it goes back in the building i go back
my truck drive back you know
then i'm just standing out there you
know 12 and jimmy comes pulling up
beat to [__] rx7 i'm like well this is
show business
like it was i've had bondo all over you
know parks's
truck and parks is rx7 and i go okay
and we just we go down the bodies in
motion
we train for like 20 minutes and i'm
like you want to get a snapple
and he's like yeah let's get a snaffle
if we go up to the cafe this is what's
snapping was a big deal
upstairs and for two hours we just sit
there talking about our favorite
comedians
and comedy and shooting the [__] sort of
falling in love
and it's like he doesn't really want to
train and i don't really i want to talk
comedy you know
and before you know it the fight's
coming up in like three weeks you know
and i'm like
i don't know what happens after the
fight because i'm the boxing trainer guy
i called in the station a time or two
like worked
i worked a joke in like i would work but
i didn't want him to think i was the guy
who wanted to be a comedian yeah yes
cause i didn't want to freak him out
like i just want to be a comedian
i want to know i was a boxing trainer
you know
so the fight ended uh
the judges for the fight were how did
jimmy do
he lost what did you teach him i i
couldn't teach him anything
i couldn't i i i tried to do a thing
there's a picture of me and jimmy
getting into the ring
in what was called the uh blita in
receda
it took place at the merceda country
club um was he nervous
not not really which was weird he wasn't
that concerned about it
pat o'brien called it adam sandler was a
judge
wow and if you go to the left upper left
you see a picture of me
with my hat on backwards while jimmy is
wearing my old boxing trunks leaning
against the robes and michael the
maintenance man is pummeling him
that's me with my bodies in motion hat
and t-shirt on
i sent him out for the second round with
no mouthpiece i remember that
i remember like the bell rang and the
guys were fighting and at some point
i looked down i was like what's this
extra mouthpiece doing in my hand
like was my first dog my second one was
oh
but you know they had to face guard on
which kind of how long how long did they
fight for
i think it was like three minute rounds
or three three-minute rounds or whatever
it was
but the the long and the short of it was
if you go to the bottom left corner you
can see like an old picture of
me and jimmy and i'm dressed up as uh
mr birch i'm the woodshop teacher
jimmy's wearing the glasses
yep he's in the middle so
we got to the end he lost the fight
and i i was like well now what
like what could i do but you guys create
some sort of bond i'm sure throughout
those weeks
yeah you guys would hit it off
immediately yeah
and he said like do you have any
tape or you have anything that you've
done and i
shot some eagle rock like public access
home improvement thing and it was
totally rough
and totally public access and totally
whatever
but i said that's what i got and he said
i'll look at it i gave it to him
and you know the genius of jimmy he like
saw
something in it like he was like oh this
guy's good for some reason even though
he's totally
raw so jimmy got it and
he said he goes well what do you do like
what's your thing
and i said i just shoot this [__] man i
just sit
and roll with the punches and add to the
conversation can you imagine
you and i would be like well good luck
with that right so what do i do with it
he looks at me and goes
well that's what kevin and bean do and i
go yeah what i would do is like
sit in between them and like make them
better you know
and he's like nah that's never it's
never gonna work
you're the boxing coach you're not
coming into the studio and
hanging out and cracking wise and i was
like
well what do you what's your suggestion
and he's like the only way you're
getting on with kevin and bean
is you got to come up with a character
and i was like
i don't really do voices or characters
yeah i don't really do stuff
yeah right any more gray poupon
so i go i'm not it's not really my thing
you know
i'm kind of me you know and he's like
well you better make it your thing
and figure it out and that was like on a
friday
and he said call in monday
i'll give you the number i'll give you
like the hotline number i'm not going to
tell those guys
who you are because if they find out
you're my boxing coach
they're going to be like i don't want to
talk to the boxing coach guy or he's
doing a character i mean think about
what that sounds like right
so he goes i'm not going to tell him who
you are i'm just going to go
i know funny guy you know he'll do a
character like trust me
and then he said they're probably not
going to like it
and it'll probably be the last one you
do
like you're gonna it's gonna be one and
done like he wasn't saying it's gonna be
one and done but you know you're batting
average on your stupid character with
your boxing coach
and i'll ask if you can call in next
week and they'll probably go like
it wasn't that good yeah so i like went
okay i don't know i don't have any
characters
and but i sort of was gonna
fall back on like my groundlings
training like i do know how to develop a
character and i do
i do i am trained to do this stuff
so i i went back and i was like
you know i was thinking okay you're the
you're the gay florist who's gonna do
the movie reviews you know or something
it's like
i was like i'm sitting around going what
i compare
yeah why would i why would i call
my god why would i call in
what would be my motivation for calling
a radio station like as a character and
i started thinking about it and i
thought
well you have to go with something you
know
like you have to go a subject you know
about
and i knew carpentry really well and
woodworking
really well and i was like now but
what's the character
you know and i thought i always
joked about my shitty junior high shop
teachers and what dicks they were you
know mr
hensley and mr saponzi and how they
hated the kids and they kind of loved
wood and wood shop
and metal and everything but they hated
the kids you know
like the surly woodshop teacher
you know and i was like oh that would be
good like the mean
wood shop teacher and then i was
thinking to myself
but why would the mean wood shop teacher
call kevin and bean like what what's his
motivation right
calling and so i started thinking about
it
it's like oh i know okay
so this guy mr burcham
the woodshop teacher he teaches remedial
wood at louis pasteur
middle school in monrovia that's his
thing and
he is calling in at 7 15 in the morning
and the reason
he's calling in is while he doesn't like
k
rock or any of this new music [__]
his kids all listen they all have the
clock alarm
set to k-rock because their prime demo
genius they're a bunch of 13 year olds
they're skaters you know they love
k-rock yeah so so i call in
and i go you know listen
i don't care about your music i don't
care about your nervosa and your
smashing
dumplings and all your crap music you
know you know i like sugarloaf and real
bands you know
and and but all the kids are listening
so give me a second just to kind of use
it as an intercom to like speak to the
kids
and then i go off on the kids i'm like i
injured myself in the garage again i'm
not coming in that quimby mr some ponzi
with a sweater vest
he's going to be teaching my class i
don't need
look if one of you goddamn kids gets
near my drill index so help me god i'll
stab you when i come back
and leave the makita poster alone i
don't you will watch he's got a movie
set up
it's blood on the bandsaw you're gonna
watch that and you put your head on the
desk and ride out the rest of the period
do you understand
you don't get up you don't touch my
tools you don't move around
and then i'd go like and then but hold
on there's one kid who's good
you know that kid's good his name was
brad higgins dog like brad i've been
thinking a lot about the cigar box
you're building your grandfather singing
about a butt joint
i know we're talking about a dado or
rabbit joint or maybe a dovetail or a
finger joint but i
i think let's just go with a rabbit
joint that's a clean
you can set up the dado system on my
contractor saw
if any other kids get up you're in
trouble brad listen to me
and i'm getting all specific [__] of how
this thing
would be built that's so good dude
about they they liked it it went well
yeah have that guy call
in again next week and i kept calling in
and i kept the would you and jimmy
talk after like what'd you think jimmy
was like yeah yeah i i called jimmy
were they laughing like i wasn't really
because they'd have the meeting
after the show right you know and and
you know be like jimmy
you know what'd they think they thought
it was okay they i think i think you
think i could i think i'd call in
call in again oh yeah i did the burcham
on on
i do prank anchors you created that with
jimmy right
yeah how long did you guys run on that
how
we did like i don't know four or five
seasons and now
it's back yeah now it's back we saw it
more
more seasons but how happy were you when
you called jimmy how'd it go and he went
pretty well man well at the beginning it
was just like
i think you could call back next week
like i was just
living week to week to fight again those
moments when you surprise yourself
when you're desperate like i i the only
time i ever
knew i maybe had you don't know if
you're talented you don't even know if
you can do this
and i had an audition for these agents
in new york and
and you had to bring a monologue and i
was looking at monologues and i go
i want to write a monologue i was like i
wonder if i'm allowed to do it or not
bring one in no one i wrote i wrote a
monologue
yeah i wrote a monologue as a new york
guy and i did it i had no idea it was
going to work i was so [__] terrified
i was probably like 22 and i
i did this monologue it was this new
york guy and
they were [__] laughing and then he
goes where did you
where'd that come from and i go i wrote
it he goes
you wrote that i go yeah he goes you're
very talented
it was the first time anybody ever said
it was the first time i've ever heard
that you know when you hear that when
you when something works like that
you're like
maybe i can do it but you didn't know it
was working right adam you're just going
week you kind of going
just hoping to get i didn't know it's
radio so i have no idea what the
audience is laughing
they were like a little bit but it
wasn't overwhelming
but it was enough all i needed to do was
survive
to go to the next round yeah you know
and i and
and i but i knew that if the following
week
i went out there and [__] the bed
i knew they'd pull the plug on it and i
knew
i had to get you know eight or ten good
ones under my belt
before i could turn in a five you know
yeah so i
worked really hard at it and it became
like a sensation
and it was it was crazy so it's like i'm
backstage at the
at the acoustic christmas at irvine
whatever like with kevin and being like
you know two months later
and all of a sudden like i hear henry
winkler like i had like celebrities
would hang out backstage and i hear
henry winker going
and and who's mr bircham where's mr
perchem that guy's a genius
because he said that's like [__] and
i'm standing back there like i i'm
swinging ahead
for anybody who doesn't mind rainbows
young henry here was fonzie i mean right
holy [__] and and so i'm like huh and i
like walk up to him
and i go uh i'm mr bircham
and he he does the two-handed handshake
with me
now he's mine nice man i'm not even in
show business at this point i'm still
working as a boxing coach and a
carpenter he shakes my hand with two
hands and he goes
nobody does what you do nobody can do
what you do
and i was like oh my god my mind is
blown
and then like in the same concert thing
duff kagan or something from the from
guns and roses like comes by and he goes
he's like sees me and he goes you're mr
bircham
oh man axel was way off axel thought you
were an
older dude i think axel rose is having
thoughts about me like i'm i come from
the valley i'm working construction like
you and axel rose are having a
discussion mister
i get signed from william morris because
like the head guy
mark itkin over there is a huge merchant
fan
i get on the love line everyone's this
huge mr bircham fan
and it was funny and that's why the
story
who's so then so then and then you and
jimmy just kind of kept this
relationship
yeah well the the the thing that you
know about jimmy or you need to know
about jimmy is
i'm the guy's boxing coach and like 10
minutes
later i'm twice as famous as he is mr
birch
jimmy has been kicking he's been
knocking around
radio for seven years at this point like
he's in tampa
he's in he's in seattle he's getting
fired
from palm springs i come in and in two
months i'm a huge star
in radio and no one cares about him i
was like
[__] god and a lot of dudes would
have turned on me
like a lot of dudes at that point would
have went i'm not gonna help you with
your next virgin bit or i'm not gonna
edit the bit you're like a lot of guys
would have went hey man
good luck yeah he just went i'll help
you
i'll do it i've never met i never met
him but i i just i uh
i was on the same plane with him and i
watched how he interacted with fans
he's just such a good [__] guy man
he's almost such an amazing guy i've
always liked him you guys are still
close now oh yeah
he completely went to bat for me and is
that guy in the picture eight feet tall
or is it is it bean is
bean is like six six bean is successful
that was b
kevin's like six two kevin yeah kevin
yeah and
henry winkler's like five seven he's
uh i've met henry yeah he's a good man
he's
he's f1 size who who woulda f1 size
who would have thought that you and
jimmy the careers you guys
would have led to man we used to you
guys are [__] monsters
we used to do well jimmy's a monster
jimmy
you're not giving yourself enough credit
jimmy and i used to
finish kevin and bean now
you know he's he is he's not
low man on the totem bowl but there's
kevin and bean
then there's a big gap and then there's
like jimmy and the
producer uh frank is on the left of this
picture
and frank murphy and you know
jimmy didn't have any juice around the
station it's not like he could go into
kevin weatherly the program director's
office or even
kevin and bean and go here's what we're
going to do fellas like let's go no
we're not
so like we used to finish the show
and we'd go out to lunch or breakfast at
like noon
because every you know we're done with
work everyone else is
at work we're like done and we just sit
around going what could we do
like what what what show could we do
together you know
and it was like at some point some other
radio station
came calling and they're like well we do
a radio show on our station i was like
me and my buddy jimmy kimmel could do
a show on your radio station and they're
like jimmy's a behind the scenes guy
like he's a producer he's not a talent
you know like you're the talent
he's kind of the producer i don't see
you two co-hosting a show
and we were forbid for forbidden for
being on the air together
at k-rock because when we came on
together we like got
each other too goosed up or something so
nobody was like
you and jimmy have to do something but
me and jimmy were like
me and you have to do something so then
what you guys created the man show
the man show yeah we were like sitting
around
and jimmy was like at the point of his
career where he's like
starting to go out on some auditions for
like
good morning glendale they went to perky
host and the guy was
being at that point nationwide no
they're just syndicated in los angeles
but all the agents and all the other
people were out here kevin sit on the
floor back then like he does today
no he he sat upright at that stage in
his radio career
and jimmy was driving home from one of
these good morning glendale auditions
you know
and he said to me he said they want me
to be likable to women
and then he he paused and he went my
wife doesn't even like me
i said i know i know i said how could we
he said we forget about being likable
the women we should just do our own show
what's called the man show like forget
about what women think we're not going
to win them over
no we'll just we'll just lean into it
you're on my group
i'm unlikable let's do the man show the
[__]
handshake trying to make everyone happy
let's just lean into it
how hard was that thing to get on air
though well that thing was
wasn't hard right it was it was funny
because
we um it was originally a pilot on
abc oh and
it was it was in it was initially
it was ovations it was initially a pilot
and it didn't get picked up by nbc
but eventually um comedy central picked
it up and then once it
got picked up it just like kind of
immediately became
16 and rogan was on the man's show rogan
and doug stanhope took over
yeah yeah i never you know it's weird
i don't think jimmy liked us being
replaced
i went that way i wouldn't either i just
didn't have any thoughts about it really
because that was because you guys
cultivated and created that thing
i would definitely feel some type i'd
probably be more in the jimmy
camp there i think most people would i
was
you both married back then uh i wasn't
jimmy was the i
my feeling was we created this show
[Music]
unfortunately we don't own the show we
created it
and it's super successful and
it's they're gonna do a season five and
there's really nothing we can do about
it so that's it like
i don't care like i always think it's a
bad kind of use of time when like
somebody says it's sort of like it's
like i work with mark garagos
and it's like he'll take a job defending
scott peterson
and everyone will go like you're such a
piece of [__] you're defending a
murderer it's like
somebody's got to defend this guy yeah
and that's his job and it's it's weird
for you to not like the person
like doug joe it's like their phone rang
and somebody said you want to host the
man
yeah that would host the show like of
course and the network is like
hey man we're doing gangbusters in the
ratings we're in season four
let's go to season five and the
producers are like hey that's a [__]
cash cow like
i don't know who to blame you guys
didn't want to do it anymore
no we had i think what had happened
i have to get jimmy's version of it
because
i'm never sure how it is we were like
getting
we we had completed our hundredth show
oh wow
and when this show started
i came in and so did jimmy with like a
whole shitload of like hey i want to do
this and i want to do that i want to do
this bit i want to do that bit
and by the time you do a hundred
episodes
you're like you're like it's like it's
like any band with that first grade
album because they've been
touring and playing bars and honky tonks
for 10 years
and then the record company goes put out
the next album six months later it's
like we don't
talk about anything talk to everybody
else right so
it wasn't like that like did the shows
were good
and we always made sure they were funny
and we always put a lot of time into
them and we always
really made sure they were like the
product was there but like after
a hundred episodes we're like losing i
feel like we've
said what we had had to say and jimmy
got the nod from
abc to go uh host
who's a late a host of late show and
which was a big deal right because
that's a big deal
well the biggest deal but i don't think
either you guys
thought that would happen right like
that's i don't know
i i was like this is a big deal this is
a huge
opportunity and jimmy helped me
all throughout my career and so
comedy central came to me and they're
like well jimmy's gone but you're not
you know and then we'll just hook you up
with doug stanhope or joe rogan or
whoever
they said to me you do the show any way
you want
you you do the show alone you get
another guy to fill in for jimmy however
you want to do it
we just we want to do a season five
because it was a big
blockbuster for them and they're like
jimmy was leaving but no one else was
leaving all the producers and all that
stuff
so i was like i don't want to do that i
did the show with jimmy yeah
and uh i'd like to go you know with him
to abc to like help him develop or
launch you know the late night show and
we had a lot of meetings and they kept
wanting to go out to lunch and
offer me god like 50 grand an episode
which was kind of a lot back then and
stuff
and it just seemed weird to do it
without jimmy
obviously and it's just something i
never entertained so
do you think you could do the man show
today i wonder what that'd be like
pitching that
i i feel like there's room for it now i
do feel like guys are hurting for
something like that
yeah i feel like there it is too
especially if it was on the you know if
you were on a netflix it's almost
something you started on the internet
yeah you'd have to get on couldn't be
abc or maybe even comedy central but
it'd have to
go and you'd have to kind of lean into
it like you'd have to make like
a new archie bunker you would find that
you'd find the niche
the demos the demos do you think things
change
now that we've gone through this
insanity and we are going through this
insanity i wonder what
i always wonder what the ripple effect
are it'd be nice
if we could prioritize a little bit like
i started my podcast
yesterday and the first thing i said i
went
to my studio sunday night and it's like
there's a curfew
and santa monica's burning and people
are getting stomped on in the streets
and looted
and the first thing i said is thank god
we all went nuts on jimmy fallon's black
face from 20 years ago last week thank
christ
we burned the calories i know dude
unearthed footage
unearthed it [__] aired on nbc
thank god all you dicks bought into all
this [__] like he's got to offer an
apology
yeah like yeah are you [__] idiots
like how trivial does that sound now
10 minutes ago we're all upset that the
most likable innocuous
harmless guy in the world did a comedy
bit from 20 years ago about his friend
who was in the sky right can we [__]
at least
wait for something before we [__] get
concerned
i agree exactly and how [__] stupid
do we all look on well he should have to
apolo
we [__] look like [__] right that
was like middle of last week
middle of last week it was trending it
was the number one trending thing like
god damn dude now can we use that as a
learning experience which is the next
time
what we want the zero burger comes down
the [__] pike do we all have to
pounce on it
i know that's why i say and i wonder if
we do all pounds on it or is it two
percent
so two percent of the population i
believe is on twitter
in the united states it's something very
low and there and among that there's
just
very very active [__] on both sides
of the aisle
who go crazy and the problem is
politicians
see that corporations see that because
of the way it is and it looks like
people it looks like that's in the
zeitgeist looks like it's a bigger deal
but it's not
right and reality is [__] not that
big of a deal yeah it's but people are
losing jobs over because the big deal
because
they feel the pressure from social media
really the world isn't that upset about
it but these few dumbasses are yeah
that are the the loud ones on social
media yeah yeah hey last question about
man
show and then i'll leave you alone about
it when you and jimmy were doing that
though
do you look back on it now when you're
in the moment you guys didn't realize it
was that the greatest time in your
career though
because i think about certain things i
tried to smell the roses i'm sure you
guys had so much fun man
you're with your best friend you have
this huge hit show you're doing what you
want to do
that's how i felt about houston this
weekend how much fun we had like you
have to sometimes go this is such a
blast to be together and just [__]
laughing and being silly at a certain
moment yeah but i'm sure that was
special but you're yeah you're
successful dude jimmy success you guys
are both
like these legends now but for you do
you look back on that as like a
it was a big deal did you embrace it it
was i mean
you know you never fully appreciate that
like you don't [__] appreciate youth
you know what i mean like when you're
25 and in great shape did you really
stop and count yourself
now or i didn't your body just wasn't in
the way
right but you know at some point
we had an entire building it's like me
and jimmy
shared an office with daniel kellison
and it was like the three of us just sat
in a big office
i just had a desk that faced jimmy's
death so it's like he was on that side
it's like one of those gay piano lounges
where
the guys are going to both directions
the yin and the yang
of the wang and it's like i'm like
facing him and he's faced me and i'd be
like hey man i just
lean over and let a fart go you know no
work done getting no work done and
we gotta run we got a room full of
riders but the writers are like
based on guys we want to hang out with
like everything like
not even good writers just dudes that
are cool my biggest
lament there's two writers we hired
which were funny one guy
still still working him uh adam de la
pena
he came in and the guys would come in
like i went to harvard and i was with
the national lampoon and whatever and
one guy comes in he's wearing a hawaiian
shirt but it's kind of funky
and we go me and jimmy like hey where'd
you get that hawaiian shirt
and he goes uh i made it
and we went you showed that hawaiian
shirt yourself and like
he's like yeah we like put the resume
down and we go and he goes
you hire me i'll make you guys hawaiian
sure so like you're in dude
hire that guy already i'm laughing then
there's another guy we hired based on
his softball skills
because we'd play a softball game at the
end of the year
this is the worst we play a softball
game at the end of the year right
yeah and i was like how's your softball
game i got it i play shortstop i got a
cannon for an arm i'm like oh okay
all right you're in you're in all right
that [__] wrote no jokes the entire
season
[__] sucked wasn't even there half
the time and at the end we got to the
softball game and i'm like okay
now i'm just taking you first the guy
sucked i had a wet noodle for an arm i
was like
[__] totally got [__] by this guy
[__] liar
never played softball your piece of [__]
but it's you got to be careful with how
you
but you can tell somebody's funny with a
comment like that though
yeah was that weird bro once the man
show any kind of you and jimmy going
your separate ways
i've been a little funky right it it
it's always
like you know most comedic teams
end in tragedy i mean they just martin
and lewis or whoever they just they end
up
hating each other morning shows and
hating
drive time you know i'm gonna take two
guys you put them together for extended
periods of time and tell them to do
comedy
and i hate each other you know he said
that's that's kind of what i was getting
at
uh got to adam is the kid fighter
anatomy
this is uh uh no jimmy and i
always got along and and it was like
i've always been uh kind of
philosophical
about like being a little bit behind the
scenes like i always kind
of wanted to do that like i thought i'm
gonna sit at this writer's table and i'm
gonna like write jokes and stuff
but at a certain point it's like it's
five o'clock it's time to go
and it's like jimmy we need you on stage
to you know run the monologue or
whatever
and i went and it's like hey adam go
home
and i was like okay like i kind of
liked that like i i used to i had a
weird
perspective on things like when we do
the man show
and we'd run the monologue like before
we tape two shows on like a friday night
or whatever it is
it'd be an empty studio the writers
would all just be
sitting in the bleachers or in the
audience
and they'd have to watch the monologue
see if they had any ideas or punch up or
whatever
and i remember just standing up you know
they clipped the mic on you you're in
your sweatpants but you have to go get
in hair and makeup
and blah blah blah cue cards and
everything and i would look out at the
writers
and they'd be holding a beer and like
eating a sandwich and like [__]
around throwing a nerf football around
and i would think
i wish i was there like like i i know
everyone thinks oh you wish you were the
one up on stage but i'd see these guys
drinking a beer and throwing a nerf
football and i'd be going
i want to be with you guys not up here
with the makeup and the hair and the
going over the cue cards and stuff so
i was always happy just to like slide
into the
writer's room yeah i that's
i've always had a fantasy of being an
amazing writer and never having done
anything but just sit around and think
and write
writing's a [__] though but b
that's not you no no
i tried jumping on his train no i like
to perform
i just got back i just got back from the
houston improv too
oh yeah you were there the week because
i go to the first comics and they go
adam beat you to it he was here last
week i was like damn it yeah you're the
first
guy he was the second it was good i mean
it was good for you guys i loved it
were you 75 or they were at 50 percent
we were 75. oh that's so better
i donated all the money because i was
like a [__] you know if we're barely
going to get paid give it all the food
bank and give it to the staff
and do whatever yes it felt good to be
back right little sense of normalcy
yeah do you guys i i was kind of
surprised
that i was able to kind of slip back
into the act that quick
so was i that's what i said when we came
off of stage i went because i was
i was nervous because that we haven't
performed in four months
right worried about missing tags stuff
that went back and said
i went that's crazy sure first show was
a little rough for me first show the
second show
was i was back i took one show to kick
the the
wheels the dust and the second one i
forgot a lot of [__] in the first show
in the second show
plus i had like 25 new minutes you know
so
that was weird but it was it was just so
good to be up on stage it was so [__]
good
you have more lined up adam yeah uh
i'm going to nashville tennessee i think
zany's coming up like the 12th and 13th
yeah for me most my motivation was
getting a haircut
and and going out for a steak and a
martini like
i wanted to go out for a goddamn steak
so did you go to bmb
do you know where you went yeah we we we
went to
let's see oh there i am who's that gal
that's gina grant
we we went to um
mastro's steakhouse oh nice after that
and
i love that cup you have surfing for her
yeah it was great to go to a restaurant
[__] we loved it yeah it was so great to
go to a restaurant
empty i completely completely loved it
and i got a new book coming out on the
16th of june by the way what's it called
i'm your emotional support animal oh my
god the uh
navigating are all woke no joke culture
amazing and that's my dog in my life
what's your thoughts on
uh i think it's good for everyone
involved in podcasts and rogan's selling
to spotify
oh it's awesome isn't it great it's
awesome i mean
if it's surreal but it's it's awesome
and you know i always just think that
guy's a good
that guy's a good testament to just go
out and do what you do
and just do it just do it early and
often like i used to say to everyone
when i started i started a few months
before
joe and people would say to me like i
want to do a podcast but what do you
think you know
once a week twice a week i'd go just go
out and do it just go out and do it and
they'd go
well i couldn't do more than once a week
and i'd go why not you know they go well
because i need to
and i'd be like all right if you're
already making excuse you're already
making excuses like we're already
bargaining like
yeah it's like you're talking to dr drew
and going i'll give up the fentanyl
but i still need a little whiskey every
once in a while on the quail
like if you're negotiating you're not
clean no
you do it either you want to do it or
you don't want to do it yeah cause you
started a couple of months before rogan
was it on this no because on uh my other
show that we had a fan question said who
are the
the you're the godfathers of podcasting
your godfather
my goat's a podcast and you were i said
adam carolla
rogan and marin yeah i got a somebody
sent me a
tweet a couple of days ago and there
it was from december 09
and it was joe saying just got back from
the adam corolla show
thinking about doing some online stuff
like a little more consistency
tom greenlee did you and i think that
yeah like i mean he came to my warehouse
and saw my studio and he was like
same studio and now yeah saying i gotta
bring my brother he's like the biggest
race car fan
well the race cars and you can find
pictures of the race car
you've been there a museum or something
like after a race car museum
that's a separate building that building
is
a block away and that's that's the
building where you do all the docks
but even your podcast studio has all
that race stuff it's got
some but the building you want yes that
that's crazy that building
i noticed you're going to be in
minneapolis by the way in july
oh yeah acme comedy club yeah i uh so
it's on the car the regular car one
not the race cars i don't have many
street cars anymore most of the cars i
have are raising how many cars do you
how much i bought a 4.8 million dollar
[Music]
porsche
a 4.8 i mean i couldn't come close to
spending that on do you have
there's a mirror you're looking at a
mirror you're looking at a lamborghini
350 gt
you're looking at a lamborghini mirror
and uh you're looking at a lamborghini
is
laro i sold all of them
and the reason i sold all of them is
because i bought a 4.8
million dollar porsche what the [__]
when
what went on right
not his you know what else is cool first
car
ever sponsored by apple and now i gotta
pour myself
a shot
so i made a documentary leave on the
story
can you hold it for a second can he hold
this p or
both and tell me when oh that's good
thanks
um i'm gonna get a cup too and i'm gonna
pee hold the story
all right i'll sing the dreidel song
i had a little dreidel i made it out of
clay
and when it's dry and ready it's radical
oh dreidel dreidel you know what's funny
talking to the engineer now yeah
i was uh i was always italian
until i got into comedy and then
everyone thought i was jewish
but if i had to guess i would say you're
jewish
right but what if you only knew i was a
carpenter and a boxing instructor
would you still think no i was jewish
italian all the way
right corolla so it's it's interesting
when you switch
your job you can switch you know
everyone has their
preconceived notions look they're
rightfully so there's a lot more italian
boxing coaches than there are
jewish boxing coaches and there's a
there's a lot more
jewish comedy riders in their italian
company right so that's the math
that society does and by the way i don't
blame them they're just they're kind of
playing the odds you know
for sure um there's a picture of that
car probably at auction for like 4.4
million bucks
and there's also a picture of it in the
um also picture of it in the
apple delivery
tell all the jokes you want because i
hate are we just getting hot
is this thing
is it the one right here gooding company
yeah so
so i did a movie
so i got three docs out
on netflix now i have uh
no safe spaces which i'm in which is not
on netflix
sorry you're not on netflix the uh it's
got the 24-hour war
which is ford v ferrari which is the
movie that they based the movie off of
yeah so i did ford v ferrari the dock
before the movie two years before the
movie came out i just thought
i don't know if they're i'm not saying
they're copying me but we did that
first of all before you go on have you
tried this whiskey it's goddamn good
thank you keep going it's so
smooth it's a nice scary smooth so
scary what is it by the way
makato 23 aged how much is that a bottle
a thousand dollars a gram oh my god
thank you i mean look at him
that's whiskey on the earth
so um [__] it's good so i make the movie
so
so uh shelby american which is the story
about carol
shelby is up on netflix
uh the 24-hour war is up on netflix and
uppity the first black about the first
black race car driver
at indy is up there up there too which
they want to make into a feature
by the way yeah because it's a great
story it's the first black driver at
indy
and all the trials and tribulations of
dealing with uh
indie and you know racism and racing it
wasn't just
pretty white it wasn't just indy it was
all the way through
trans am series and blah blah blah
anyway i make this newman dock
in in the middle of the newman dock uh
winning the racing life of paul newman
paul newman
goes to le mans it's the biggest race
in the world biggest most prestige
international
whatever and you can find pictures of
paul newman
at le mans from nineteen cents a town in
france
yeah okay it's out i've been there uh
it's a it's about a two two hour train
ride
out of paris to get to to get to le mans
posters you go upper right there now was
he he was a very short guy i think he
was five seven or maybe even shorter
yeah he's like five why are you so into
it he's f1 short
i didn't i didn't want to be into him
it's just one of those things so
he's at le mans so i do this whole part
in the dock about paul going to le mans
paul going to the biggest race in the
world all the paparazzi in europe like
bugging him jumping out they couldn't
get his car out of the pit you know
people are taking pictures and in the
way and
he's he wants to go do the race but he
doesn't
he he can't take the paparazzi and
everything so this whole story
and when i'm doing this story i'm
looking at this car
and i go that's a 9 that paul newman
drove
at lamaze like that's the holy grail of
all paul newman cars cause the other
ones
nissans oldsmobiles a lot of other race
cars but not at le mans
he didn't drive it at le mans so
i finished the dock i was kind of
curious where that car is
and then like two years later i find out
it's coming up for auction and
there's it'll come up for auction at
pebble beach at gooding
and company and it's it's never going to
come up for auction and some guy's going
to buy it
go back to europe with it and it'll
never come up for sale again
so i'm like you got one shot at this car
but
like i don't have four or five
million bucks you know that's how much
it was going to fetch
the auctions have estimates
and and usually have an estimate if they
say
price upon request or estimate upon
request
it usually means it's over 10 million
bucks jesus
so if you're doing a ferrari gto and it
says like inquire
that's a bad sign it's like market price
for lobster yeah
you can't afford it yeah yeah
so the estimate i think was like between
four million and five million bucks and
i was like
the response okay and i was like
i can pony up a million bucks i think
and then i can borrow the rest of my
then i could sell
every street car i have to pay for the
one
car so we bid and you needed this car in
your
it's like this it's got to be a passion
i mean they're
like anybody who's thinking about doing
that that's history yeah but that's
that's a that's a definition to me of a
passion where you go
i have a million i could sell my street
cars and raise them
but it's also a good investment too
though that car is only gonna go up in
value
maybe huh yeah it'll 100 it'll be where
it's only one
it'll be worth 10 million bucks in five
years or something or
it'll be worth a lot but i mean there's
no guarantee and also i want to drive it
i want to erase it oh my god when you
drove it on uh jay leno's garage
yeah there was a car issue with it there
was a car
there was a car issue with the 300 zx
two plus two i drove there wasn't
i thought you drove this with leno i did
drive this car with leno
i did not have a car i did not have a
motor issue with it
when i drove this car when i drove the
other car
at uh sonoma i had a motor issue
so you're kind of right that it's a leno
leno's garage episode and i did drive
this
you can see me drive this car at laguna
seca
in a vintage in a vintage race
i can show you what one lap looks like
or sounds like
in that car it's a twin turbo
uh probably makes about
650 maybe 700 horsepower and i don't
think people realize
how um how good paul newman was at
racing for doing it for such a short
time
oh he was good was he put
let's see yeah put the fourth oh you can
oh you can watch me spin out if you want
the fourth you want to go uh go down
yeah go down to that one
let's see if that's who that one sounds
like let's see
[Music]
i don't know i don't know there's a
chance you can crash this 4.8 million
dollar car
good chance oh yeah now go to let's see
let's go another one i'll find you a
start of one of these
things in front of you sweet too oh
they're all
they're all sweet let's see uh
do you still have that seventy-five
spins out in this paul newman porsche
i'll save that for a decent
go to the 2017 let's see if they have
that
that one do i have the 74 yeah i have
that i have that porsche yeah
so if you go to if you go to the rolex
historics race
at laguna seca they have
a big vintage race every year i'm going
i'm going this year they got canceled
this year didn't it the pebble beach
got canceled pebble beach got cancelled
but the race
at the track is still on but the show's
done
the show all the events are cancelled
but it's not the track
are you nervous here when you start
riding
not as much as you'd think although
probably is the money going through your
head at all
no no my my feeling is if i ruin the car
we'll have to fix it
and it's been it's been crashed it it's
been crashed a few times so you go
through this whole
throng of crowd and then they grid you
up
on how you qualified and there's
probably 50 cars
in the race and they point you they put
you into your grid spot
and then once you get into your grid
spot when you pull out
onto the track you have to pull out
according to your grid spot so they go
that way
that way that way so you're next to each
other like
like a regular like a regular race and
then they
they do a parade lap
just so you can like get heat
so you can get heat into the tires
basically that's why people
zig and zag just to try to warm up the
tires and then at some
point the pace car pulls off
and they drop the green flag
that's so cool man
jesus christ and everyone goes [__]
i have to say that's pretty [__] cool
dude you're moving
yeah the car is flying what the [__] how
fast are you going
i got 135 140 at the end of the day but
you're simply too fast right
watch out watch how squirrely the guy in
the blue porsche gets like
this porsche is so nice though oh yeah
he's all over the place
so there's a bunch of those are like
rsrs these these would be vintage horses
or these would be those are all vintage
yeah they're all vintage cars there's a
bmw
m1 pro car that's like a little bit of
ahead of us
none of them are streets so that rsr is
right
okay so this is basically
what one of these crs are yeah well he
doesn't have turbos
still though now this this next guy i'm
gonna kind of stuff myself
into which is like a little like
he could it was a little late for a pass
there
you go up the back hill i'm gonna miss a
shift here because i never drive this
car
that was a second instead of fourth then
you drop into the
carousel which is this famous turn here
there's this big elevation do these
other racers judge you because you're
adam corolla or they're like oh
they like they want to race that i i i
judge you for having paul knew
how long how long has this race is this
race uh this be about 11
11 or 12 laps maybe they're gonna go 25
minute run groups now
and so what they'll do is you get real
close there that bmw in front of you
sweet
what surprise to win this thing
um nothing
i won the rolex cup one year in a dawson
now everyone asked that oh it's saying
they don't give you a paul newman
daytona no it's the weirdest thing
they should not give it out because
every single person
i go i won the rolex cup and i go oh
cool so come with a watch and i go no
and they go oh bummer sorry
and they walk out of the room and i'm
like well i still won the i still got a
cup though
they should give you a daytona rolex for
your troubles it'd be nice so
are you a watch guy no just a car
although newman's
watch sold for like 18.7
million bucks so here's the thing that
that paul newman rolex the white daytona
four years ago me and jay talk about
this time four years ago you could have
went into any rolex dealer any
dealer and get a get a daytona now you
cannot get them
the the price of those have escalated to
enormous amounts
all because this paul newman white
daytona
the uh the hottest one it's the ultimate
watches it hammered
wow for 15.5 but with the vig
with the auction house 10 or whatever it
was it went for
17.8 million and you want to know the
crazy thing about that so they wanted
like
that thing went off in new york and they
wanted my
porsche there like hey this is the car
he drove and the watch he
wore and blah blah that car was in the
apple
it's the only car ever put in apple
livery
don't you love two good things you learn
from racing
livery and scrutineering the scrutineers
they look at your car to make sure it's
a period correct routine ears i'd love
to have that job
that sounds like elvis back up band and
now elvis presley is screwed
jerry seinfeld says the ultimate watch
if you're a porsche guy is the daytona
you shouldn't have a porsche
not have a daytona jesus so they uh
they they did this car in apple
livery the next year and it was driven
at le mans as an
apple sponsored car it's the only if you
go back you can see the apple head
luncheon go back you can underneath this
one
yeah back yeah yeah you'll see
underneath the apple levered porsche 935
so that's that's not the car but that's
a replica
of that car but that's what that car
that's what that car looked like
and uh and uh bobby ray hall
won daytona 24 hours a daytona outright
in that car you know that yeah no and it
also won sebring outright so it's got
tons of history so with vintage cars
it's all about history and so this has
tons of
tons of le mans races and and everything
else
just different but paul newman is so hot
right now i mean everything
everything of his is his watch his car
well
the salad dressing you know it you know
what's weird
is i kind of studied it it's like
there's a period like a steeping or
cooling off here yeah like if you go up
or left in that picture that's just a
picture of that car from
the day it's the same car wrap or paint
right different paint so the
um so after steve mcqueen died steve
mcqueen
died in like 1980. no one gave a [__]
about steve mcqueen or steve mcqueen
steve mcqueen had some motorcycles some
jackets he had some lama stuff
and some porsches and some whatever and
it was like
turn the page he's gone he's dead but
then
it took about 20 years and then steve
mcqueen's [__] got
really hot like this is his sunglasses
and this is his watch is his bomber
jacket and this is
the car from le mans this is his
personal porsche that he'd gotten
71 you know and so i started noticing
what was going on with the steve mcqueen
stuff and
at the time you know newman was still
alive but i was like
it's not like the celebrity dies
and then the [__] gets popular it's like
the celebrity dies
in 10 or 20 years goes by and then it
it's like it's like they do with the
doors or any of these movies you know
like
uh bohemian rhapsody you know
he's dead and then 20 years later 25
years later
30 years later you know it's like they
don't do it they don't strike while the
corpse is hot they wait a long period of
time so
i was kind of like i bet
i i think newman and also
newman was a real racer he won four
championships as a race car driver
and his passion was very much like a jet
championship legit
yeah he was he was a legit racer and he
doesn't have like a lot of
you know me too baggage or any of that
like he wasn't he was a good married
seriously didn't he donate all the
proceeds from his dressing
uh to charity oh yeah he didn't take
anything still does he he was
dead he's been dead for a while but he
he he was married to joanne woodward
forever i remember when they said how do
you make the relationship work you're
both movie stars
it was it's impossible it's impossible
then and it's impossible now
right he's like a guy's guide too oh
yeah and he was a he was a stud but he
wasn't like
you know now our heroes you know they
look like the rock or on sports name or
some [__]
they had like a regular dude yeah
handsome son of a [__]
yeah always always in shape yeah yeah
you're right
so wasn't when people were lifting crazy
weights i wasn't i wasn't ever
a a newman guy i was a datsun guy
and datsun newman drove for dodson
so i was like if i'm gonna get a
so i i started buying old dots and race
cars to go talk about vintage
cars racing old dots in race cars and
newman
was up in connecticut and he raced for a
guy named bob
sharp and bob sharp was from connecticut
and limerock was their was their home is
dobson the company is that a german
company or their nissan oh they're
nissan
is that japanese yeah so they
dotson has always been nissan at some
point they just changed it
from from nissan you know the thing
that's funny about
datsun and nissan is if you show
the livery the paint scheme of
the major datsun race team so you have
bob sharp's race team
he's out of the north um up north you
i'm not up north but he's in the east
sorry you have
a bre which is a pete brock's race team
red white and blue you have
electromotive red white and blue they
were
out of out of here it's all red white
and blue
and you go what are the chances that all
these
dots and race teams are red white and
blue
and it's like well they just got done
bombing pearl harbor like 10 minutes ago
oh yeah they're trying to stay they want
to sell a few units they want to sell
some z
cars and some 510s here yep and uh
you know going full torah toratora on
the roof of the car is probably not
going to get it sold
so we're going red white and blue [__]
yeah we are and we'll sell some units
like
yeah if you all the all the major race
teams
for dodson were red white different
paint schemes but all but all red white
american red white how we go through all
kinds of light
blue and your daily because you drive
you know these race cars in your daily
driver do you drive a pretty
suped up car no all the guys were you
and matt
are you are you dad dad mobile now yeah
i mean it's like you
you are it's like you don't want to get
in a street fight you know what i mean
like you get it out in the gym
you know like and also once you drive
that 9
35 in a real race on a real track do you
really want to be like
looking for cops when you [__] drop
the clutch on the
side street you know he still drives his
rs2
whatever oh yeah gt2 rs he's he drives
it that's his primary car
it's in the show it's getting tuned
right now literally brendan's primary
car
well here's my feeling i'm gonna put a
roll cage in it
i i like putting a roll cage in it i
love all right it's 900 horsepower he's
getting it souped up
he's out of his mind no i you know
here's my
here's my my thing it's my theory it's
why
it's why i believe richard gere put a
gerbil up his ass
because after you've been [__] cindy
crawford for four years
where do you go where do you [__] go
oh you can [__] a raider at like uh
yeah all right like you know what i mean
where do you go from there
wrap up your gerbil and then you're done
stick it right up your ass
so trim its nails and [__] have at it
but i'm going to bring this home put a
gerbil
so i just drive a infinity truckster
around it's a big you know
throw the kids in the back and go to the
home depot and get a piece of plywood
two and then the third that's not mine
that i just abduct no
i have i have two kids and then when i
climb into the race car it's like
oh yeah now we're ready ready to go so
it's like i
don't want to enjoy myself that much on
a daily
daily basis nothing
i used to be like a little more that way
now it's like
did you have a jag i mean yeah i've had
some good stuff but i'm like
the older i get it's like fly under the
radar
go to
hey i was for i just out of necessity i
just drove it
for transportation how long ago though
oh just 19. i've had i've had a couple
ninja 600s at a honda 404 had a couple
enduros and i just drove
like for transportation back uh
god that was fun though back when they
look fun that's why i draw the line
until you [__]
die i can't do it yeah it's fine
it's it's it's it's hairy it's scary but
you get to where you're going
so [__] fast i get jealous when i'm
sitting in traffic
and they they go between i'm like yeah
but somebody opens their door anything
can happen you're just so
[__] it's just oh no i was talking to
one of the dealers i thought about it
and he goes
i go oh yeah i go he said something like
well if he crashes well hold on have you
leaked the stats
not a few crashes everybody crashes
you're gonna crash
it depends how bad especially if you
didn't grow up riding motorcycles you're
gonna crash
yeah yeah i had a i just rode
i my first transportation was a honda
there's a picture me in a bathrobe
standing by a honda 404 and a
datsun pickup truck that was my
construction pickup truck
out front of my apartment building in
like 1985.
i i don't know how the internet works
it's always a change to be a picture of
me
like i don't think you're not driving
motorcycles i don't even know what you
you
just type it i just typed
motorcycle or something we'll see we'll
see what happens if pavement is too
unforgiving and so are other cars oh
yeah
like i i kind of knew oh yeah if you go
there you go see how many what that's
pretty cool
there's me in my datsun pickup truck
with my bed box
that's great my toolbox on the back of
the dots dots and trucks are so
tiny and i'm standing in a bathroom
somebody gave me
and i lost the tie for it and i couldn't
buy a new
tie or a ford a new tie so i just had to
hold it
shut with my dude this morning this
morning i did timely story this morning
i helped my uh my girl has a thousand
dollar bed she
she bought two months ago and she's got
she needs
she's got too many [__] beds don't
ask why she's
so the guy she works with wanted the bed
frame
brand new he puts it in his truck
puts it we helped him get it right in
his truck frame and everything
beautiful bed now i looked and i was
like i want this bed
cool well he's going to drive down to
long beach problem is he didn't
he didn't talk down down and it was in
the back of a truck like that
that here
and it hit it but no one said hey you
should tie this down dude and the
mattress is heavy it's
all grown people with
is this thick it's very dangerous
because it's this thick so if you hit
that i know
i hit one of this on the highway and i
almost [__] crashed
no you or him we're like yeah you don't
think we should maybe put a belt i left
i thought because there were mover guys
there so i thought the guys would do it
like hey mover guys
somebody tie this down nah that'll be
fine you know you do that you're like
i'm not going for her
it turns out mover guys are just stupid
guys they're not
mover guys like you don't be viewers
gonna think of anything i've never had
i've never moved my house
when somebody didn't steal something
from me really in the case
i've lost two guns a shotgun and a
[__] pistol
you let them move your guns i lost
artwork everything i
didn't they
maybe i no no it was i moved the gun but
then when they're coming stuff
when they're coming in they're coming
out somebody picked something up
um that was a long time ago i sold my
motor
i sold one of my uh ninja 600s to a guy
he showed i was like 25. he showed up
with his girlfriend
because his girlfriend like dropped them
off and
you know and it's like paid me the cash
that's like
1200 bucks or something he got on the
ninja
he took off down the street it's
actually the street where this
picture is like he took off down the
street i was like
waving goodbye to him he goes in and
dumps it
he totally crashes it on the first turn
he's ever taken on a motorcycle and he
comes back
he's got road rash all over him he's
shaking like a leaf because when you
crash a motorcycle yeah you're totally
freaked out
die i'm still standing on my lawn with
this 300 bucks in my
gym pants you know and he goes i i don't
want the bike
i don't want the bike anymore i don't
want the bike anymore i want my money
back and i was like
well you have to sell your motorcycle
like i have to sell
your it's your you you can sell it
i'm not buying it you can sell it and he
goes
i just i just want the money back and
it's like normally you can [__]
people but i'm holding the money and
standing on my lawn like he knows i have
his cash right
it wasn't a check or anything so he he
goes
i i just want my money back and i'm like
well i don't know what kind of damage
you did to the bike or whatever
and so he goes i don't want anything to
do with it and i'm like
okay well good by the way because you
would have killed yourself i'm sure
so i go all right let me see if i can
figure this out
i rode the motorcycle to a like an
independent motorcycle repair shop
the gear shift the peg was
busted off the right side
and i'm trying to think oh brakes on the
right yeah i think the oh no brakes on
the left gear shifts on the right
you got to check me on that one i
haven't ridden one wow but he
oh no the brakes on the right and the
gearshift anyway he broke the peg off
on the gear shift side yeah that's the
brake
on the right so the gear shifts on the
left he broke the peg off
so i had to ride this motorcycle to a
motorcycle repair place
with no peg like if you can't put your
heel on something and shift up and down
yeah just for
foot like floating in the air like
trying to kick it kick it down
i rode it into this place they repaired
the bike
it cost a hundred bucks i i wrote it
home like two
two days later i get a call because this
is back when it was in the recycler
newspaper like no internet anything
it's like some guy calls me he's like
you still got that bike for sale
like kind of and it's like and he's like
i'll take it
and i sold it to another guy the guy
who was freaked out i just took the
hundred bucks i backed 100 bucks out
that it cost
to fix the bike and just sent him
send him the new check so yeah i'm sure
the guy
bought it guys memory man you remember a
lot of details i i it's a weird story
that i'll never forget
let's do current events i want to get
your take on some stuff sure
all right here we go okay
so this video has been going viral it's
a
sheriff over in missouri for uh i mean
uh
michigan flint michigan he went viral
because
people started to record his speech
where he basically said that
he is trying to help his community and
he's there to protect protesters he's
not there to stop
them from voicing their opinions and he
took off
his helmet he made sure all of his
officers took off their helmets
put down their batons and they actually
marched with protesters
wow he's a police what he is the sheriff
of
the flint michigan police department
we want to be with you all for real so i
took the helmet off they laid the batons
down
yeah i want to make this a parade not a
protest
so listen i'm just telling you these
cops love you
that cop over there hugs people so
you need to do
[Applause]
how cool is that how [__] cool is
that
i don't know i don't like it i don't
like all the feel good
you know the cops look at them they're
taking a knee it's like a pepsi
commercial
or one of the kardashians hence a pepsi
uh uh stormtrooper i'm like it's it's
all good
but i don't know that it really gets at
the heart of the problem like there's
still guys coming back with
sledgehammers tonight
right yeah but it just shows you the
majority of people are good people and
the majority of people
oh the majority the majority of people
on both the planes that hit the twin
towers were good people
i'm gonna i'm gonna say it someone needs
to say
the lion's share of the people on both
those planes
good people unfortunately there was like
two bad dudes no and they only goes a
lot
one guy one piece of [__]
murdering cops
and ruin everything over 50 of the
people on those planes were good
is what i'm saying but
there is a couple of but we know that it
takes a couple of bad apples to [__]
everything up
it's so funny it's possible you know
most of folks at jonestown were family
oriented folks but jim jones
jim jones was not a good night he was
not he spiked the kool-aid but he got a
lot of
a thousand people laughing committed
suicide law abiding
family oriented like the god fearing
yeah so that's my point it's it's a
numbers thing it's a numbers thing
numbers yeah there's one two people do a
lot of damage
this is just a silly video of a bear
breaking into a car
oh yeah i saw that we love bears don't
we
damn how do you not open it up like that
and he's walking on this he's like what
the [__]
he's so excited he was actually startled
too
god scared the [__] out of that bear so
the bear
went and essentially used its paw
to uh open the door and then some a
bunch of people
i don't know who those people were
because that that felt a little more
like mardi gras than camping
like that did not feel like the camping
crowd it was a more reserved
crowd that didn't feel like a trail mix
crap like who was making that kind of
noise
yeah we're probably trying to scare it
away it's a small bear yes
small brown bear it's a baby bear yeah
shouldn't you lock your mercedes when
you go camping
and then and the key would work from
there to lock it
i also shouldn't we be done being
surprised by
bears showing up places because like
we're in la canada and a bear showed up
in our swimming pool like
how many of those stories you have to
hear before you go down all the animals
being like hey
bear show up places that's a tiger get
out in oakland
yep a tiger was really well during the
big escape
but yeah there's a tiger loose that'll
scatter a protest
it's not a bad idea one large tiger is
probably a good lisa tiger
i was thinking about [__] with things
i was thinking about tigers at the zoo
the other day
and everyone's like oh it's inhumane and
then other people like oh they have a
nice habitat you know they can roam
around but
how about the fact that the tigers
can probably smell the gazelles
and all the [__] they would normally do
yeah
like right over there like wouldn't that
freak you out
tigers did not get out by the way that's
like you go to the champagne
room at the strip club but you you're
[__] zip ties and somebody's got your
dick duck
duct tape your leg and it's like that's
just torture at this
point right [__] thing about it you
can't do anything about it the tigers
got to be going nuts like there's
there's all the [__] there just hanging
out
you can tell their souls are just gone
in their eyes they're just [__] up man
depleted
last week we talked about a huge pool
party that happened over in the ozarks
apparently one person who went to the
party
didn't feel good the day after she went
to go get tested
turns out he's positive for kovid 19. he
was actually
already positive with it when he came to
oh really
oh no so they're saying that probably
gonna spread herself
this guy's got a higher batting average
than my pool party because i throw a
pool party eight people on average feel
bad
the next day some is a sexual nature and
then others just drank too much
when i peed that kind of stuff went over
overloaded the nachos a little bit but
mostly people feel bad after a pool
party
so it's just one feels bad alcohol they
say he's okay now
um they are basically saying that
they're just making sure that he stays
home for the time being now that he's
tested possibly
we're gonna have and they're trying to
get people who were at the party to also
stay home
i was watching cnn and you know
protesters it's on fire behind the lady
and i told you this story it's on fire
and she's interviewing guys you know how
it never goes well
and she goes sir how are you feeling
lowers the mask he has like uh
like a thing you can leave your mask on
he goes [__] trump she goes okay just
calm down
and she goes are you worried about the
spread of corona during this thing he's
like
what they just seem like go kicking off
[__] racism trumps corona we all know
that now
nobody gives a [__] about corona right
now everybody's like [__] no one's even
talking about
no nothing and and uh and again like
like you said certain priorities
priorities but at the end of the day
it's funny to me it's it's it's going to
be
interesting to see if we have a spike in
corona cases or will those young people
who are protesting be asymptomatic
well think about it that's one way to
get hurt immunity i was talking to uh
dr drew about it earlier actually
earlier today on my podcast which was
okay so cnn has been feeding us the
steady diet of like you can go to the
beach
but no hand-holding and you have to walk
into the wind and no sand castles
and if you want to lay down you can't
and like i literally hear these
[__] [__] going like what if
someone lays down who's going to enforce
that like what if someone puts a towel
down
who's going to enforce that it's like
okay two weeks ago they were [__]
worried about people laying down on the
beach
now there's throngs of people shouting
in each other's faces
tear gas everyone's coughing and rubbing
their eyes
spittle everywhere and screaming and
wrestling with cops
all over the country times a thousand
times hundreds of thousands of human
beings and
this [__] is now six days old dr drew
said it's basically three to seven days
like they do the
two weeks but two weeks is an outlier if
you get this [__] you're gonna get it in
three to seven days
eighty percent of the people who get it
are gonna show something in
three to seven days it's been three to
seven days
minneapolis started for sure a week ago
okay so where are all the new cases
and if they're not any new cases then
shut the [__] up yeah but then let us go
to the beach
because cnn's ratings are in the
dumpster because they're they're [__]
well the radiance are happening now
because they're
pretty because they're preaching yeah
but they're they they
suck and fear and people really watch
cnn on their way to the airport like
when they're at the airport
so so they know this so this is they
can't let this go i i
get it but at what point like the
[__] lemmings that are watching like
so how about doctor i don't know go
ahead how about dr
drew get taking so much [__] when he's
like i i think
what we're doing is we're kind of you
know we're bunkering down and
for we're kind of overestimating how
powerful this thing is going to be it's
actually a lot less
you're not [__] you know you're not
out of control you're not vouching
you're showing up guys and he actually
he actually had to issue an apology was
like listen i'm not saying they're wrong
i'm just saying we're taking too many
caution it turns out he was right right
he's spot on yeah well
where are those people now yes they're
still out here they're still out there
saying we need to get like my daughter
my [__] children have to go to public
school and
they're talking about two days a week
it's not good for my children's psyche
so
[__] you hey did you see him yeah jimmy
fallon and dr drew had to issue apology
that's my apology i i can't stand cnn
and they're
they're driving me nuts back to the
protest you see that uh
i wish she was the better looking lady
but you see the lady [__] on the car
no she's [__] on a car it's just they
like it's a cop car
like spray paint and then just this
warlock of a woman gets on there and
pulls her pants
and shits all over the car i need to and
they're all like yeah
i mean like you guys are worried about
like i like the mayor of atlanta
like the mayor atlanta this is not a
that [__] is not a protest that's
chaos and and you're [__] and
is she better than the chick out of
canada that was in a dunkin donuts or
something who's [__] in her hand
nope i i i i girl she's taking a [__]
on the car she hasn't been on the cop
she's a mohawk sir on the cop car yeah
overturned cop car too she's [__] on
like the
israelites she's sitting on the back of
it on the bottom well they flipped it
over
yeah what's she doing oh look at her
or was she able to manage a duke well
you know the good news is there's a neck
brace on
the guy's wearing the air airplane
around his neck
at some point she's gonna discover jesus
christ
in her 60s and then but this will always
live on the internet you know what i
mean yes and she's going to be a mom
she's going to be preaching to her flock
and talking about sins
i hit rock bottom when i shot on a
police car
i didn't see that's right i'm glad you
told me about that that's right
i will not be the same after that but
there it is any comments on that
it'll be well it'll be refreshing
because most people hit
rock bottom when they're like i took my
kids piggy bank
i broke it open and i saw myself in the
mirror
yeah and i knew that's when i needed
help and then she's gonna go
i was [__] on a cop car and
everyone's the whole room's gonna go
what
and this because most of them are like
you don't think that morning when she
saw herself in the mirror with a
mohawk she had a idea everybody will be
like
you're the girl oh yeah yeah
i uh i know it's this was great cjr
smith
no basketball player he caught someone
trying to uh you know the looters came
by his car
he beat the [__] out of this looter oh i
did not see that
[__] out of him really good let me see
this please all righty
i like seeing this don't record it
please please
just respect his privacy please come on
respectfully
i'm kicking a dude i'm kicking a dude in
the head that wouldn't
be cool man respect the worst size 26
air jordans
and i'm kicking it dude in the head
piece of [__] wait was that a chicky
punch
that's what everyone thought but it's
like it looks like an actual dude
somebody's a guy
a little white antifa guy i'll [__] with
his car
hey man please probably privacy that's a
good friend
i get out of here i don't want to turn i
don't want to have turns that guy is
that guy football player
baseball basketball i don't want to take
a turn for the racial but
uh white guy's looting you know we're
hoarders
you know what i mean we're not looters
we're boarders and like we'll go in and
clean out the aisle on toilet paper
if i see a white looting we're just not
good at it as a cop might be so much
harsher on a white guy looting than a
black guy
what i'm saying is white people stick to
hoarding that's
that's our bread and butter
it doubles down essentially i just want
y'all to know right now before y'all see
this [__]
somewhere else one of these little white
boys
didn't know where he was going and broke
my window in my truck
broke my [__] there wasn't no rest this
is a residential area there was no
stores over here
no none of that [__] broke my window i
chased him down
and whooped his ass so the footage come
out and y'all see it
i chased him down and whooped his ass he
broke my window this ain't no hate
crime i ain't got no problem with no
nobody ain't got a problem with me
there's a problem with the mother system
that's it the mother
broke my window and i whooped his ass he
didn't know who window he broke
and he got his ass a giant super athlete
chases you down
that wouldn't be fun just a giant super
athlete closes in on you
that's what you of course it's what you
get you roll the dice when you break a
window
yeah you really do because you could get
an elderly man in a wheelchair
or you could get a giant nba or size
26 air jordan to put it upside your head
yeah i think we all like this right i
love it i have a favorite player right
now
yeah we all we all enjoy a little
frontier justice right
bravo is that it let's do one more quick
one yeah
it's a good one uh since brian's been
talking about getting plastic surgery
recently
yeah yeah his lips my eyelids my eyes
what's wrong with your eyelids
in my family they go like this
eventually so my mother's like get them
done now i'm like all right i'll do it i
went to
i'm going to kourtney kardashian's
doctor get him because
my castmate told me to do it and i was
like all right we'll see what it
i mean it's not you're not going to
notice
he said he said you won't notice i
promised you he said i'll just see no
problem
i wish it would look better i think i'm
going to come in you guys are going to
be i don't see any difference you know
what you should tell him
and he goes like how do you want me to
shape him you should go
oh i know make me look like i'm
listening
because i feel like
that would save you a lot of time you
know with your kids like i'm listening
to like your kids you know it's like
it's [__] whatever
like brian is so engaged she's so
interested
i'm never engaged wait wait let me see
that video all right so this was sent in
by
a fellow by the name of daniel marmolejo
and then this is a
kourtney kardashian's makeup artist
oh really yeah i have plastic surgery
too
the dude how crazy is that
i mean how amazing it looks like a
woman's body he did that on a dude
no that's him wait a minute that's
actually the maybe
marmaleo yeah and
that's his body wait a minute all right
let's just clear this up should i have a
boner
oh he got kylie jenner's ass done
god that's gonna be awesome for a
stepdad during thanksgiving
those are his hits he's gonna show up
every year with that nuts right
yeah pretty incredible right does it
just because it
can be done does it have to be done you
know what i mean
uh that's the question no i'm not into
it chin
i mean interesting i don't know dude i
was on topic it was on topic
kardashian if this guy this guy better
not never run afoul of the law like if
this guy ends up in the joint
he's definitely a bottom there's no i
think he's
i think he's i don't think i would
imagine that i think he's mr bottom in
life that's
probably going to be the point he
probably goes mr bottom
that's my dad you call me ernie
i mean that's the point for this guy
that's incredible there you go
so is he he doesn't feel like he hasn't
he doesn't look like he's just like that
i'm probably but he doesn't look like he
has a penis it looks like he's gone
through certain at some point
i don't know i don't know so what are
they there's an ass like
that they do inserts or like it's got to
be right they take this they take away
that
midsection put in your ass and then they
massage it it's a
six week process it is
i look like i'm listening and i want to
[__] flappy hot
two for one liter back it up brian
lifted ass
so they all right so they inject they
take the fat
and inject in your ass yeah but there's
no surge they're not putting
uh cutlets or anything no no they can no
because
i think it's called a brazilian black
lip it's called
real fat in your eyes and it works i
don't have enough dick
to really be attracted to that you know
what i mean
i love parking out of it yeah [__]
cessna
big hanger you know what i mean like
there's just not
there's not enough there's too much
clearance like i i don't know
yeah i feel like you're like a regular
ass i like a regular ass
like a flat ass i'll i'll you know my
whole thing
i guess my whole thing is sort of like i
like i like an ass
kind of a boob guy like i'm kind of like
uh show me the boobs i'm i'm looking for
differences between me and them yeah you
know what i'm saying
i have short hair so i like long hair
yeah i got a
b cup so i like a d cup you know what i
mean like i'm looking for
some separation i don't get the dudes
they're like you know the dudes that
like the 18 year old just sort of a
cups like built like a teenage boy and
it's like what that's just
looks like me when i was when i was 14.
what are we what are we looking for that
for
everybody has their thing you're in
nashville you're in minneapolis
yeah your book is called uh kansas city
here i come uh my book is called uh i'm
your emotional support animal
uh navigating our all woke no joke
culture and it's out the
16th but you can of june but you can
pre-order you've always been pretty
articulate on that subject
yeah yeah this one i go hard into it you
guys
in your audience anything in the book
anything in the book that you
would not have in there now that all
this [__] has come out
uh maybe half of it or so
uh i just leaned into it i wrote in 50
years wallaby chicks like 10 years ago
and most that [__] came true and this
one is like [__] i'm going right
back to that like no more jokes about
being a dad or anything i'm just going
right
right into it and and when you write a
book
like you know when you're doing a
podcast sometimes you have to watch it
if you're doing
panel on a late night show sometimes to
be a little careful
even sadly stand up now you have to kind
of think about what you're saying a
little bit
you write a book you just go [__] it yep
you just go all
in yeah i'm corolla.com tickets
and get your books i'm glad you finally
got to do this podcast
yeah maybe man do it more i love it
great story me and brennan are going to
be in
phoenix come see us saw that already
wow tim won't be with us where you guys
going in phoenix
stand up live oh that's great i think
they're they're saying it's 85
85 capacity oh really i'm going to be in
dallas
and in san antonio at some point
but it's going to be in june and july so
uh
spokane we added a late show thursday
that's the 25th of june those tickets
are sold out
the thick boy bike club first inaugural
ride is that saturday the 27th
sign up sign up at thickboyride
gmail.com salt lake city wise guys
tickets for that july
16th through the 18th we're also doing a
bike ride there
sign up for that a thick boy ride at
gmail.com
that's it man t5k.com adam we love you
man
thanks man thanks for having me this the
fun kid route